This is Jocko podcast number
87 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
I'd been away from infantry and from the
army I'd grown up in for far too long.
Walking through the gates of
Coleman barracks was stepping
into the welcome past.
The old army had not died after all.
The 18th was military perfection.
Men stepped smartly across my tip,
meticulously kept the grounds,
starched uniforms, blue
infantry, scarves, dazzling,
shiny brass and boots,
snappy salutes and cheerful.
Good afternoon,
sirs marked my journey to
the HBCU where I'd sign in.
The spirit of this fine unit
was already infecting me.
The hot stifling windless day,
the ragweed pollen that blew in from
adjacent fields covering the camp and
immediately activating my hay fever.
Okay.
The rundown boring camp itself,
none of it mattered as inwardly.
I was transported to an island
oasis on touched by turbulent seas.
Okay.
And it was all thanks to one man,
the battle group commanding officer
who would forever be my model,
mentor and friend,
Colonel Glover.
S Johns was the finest senior infantry
commander I'd ever seen or ever would see
again.
We shared a mutual abiding respect
almost from the moment we met.
He was my kind of soldier and I was his.
He was a warrior patents
aid before World War Two.
Then during the war,
he'd hit the beaches of Normandy as part
of the 29th division and fought from
those bloody shores all the way across
Europe until victory was achieved as a
battalion commanding officer.
He had headed the task force,
the captured the critical
French town of St Lo
in Korea.
He'd served as executive officer,
then regimental commander
in my own 40th division.
His reputation there was awesome.
One story that made its way through the
division was that a wild new XL had come
into the two to fourths, gotten down on
his belly in the mud to check the units,
machine guns,
field of fire,
and promptly moved two thirds of the
machine gun bunkers that had sat there for
two years.
Okay.
Later when he took over as commanding
officer of the two to 24th and the unit
move to a new sector,
he'd outpost to dispar about 200 yards
in front of one of his companies so the
North Koreans couldn't do at first
with this move was considered seizing
ground and against no when rules of the
war and soon the XCOR commanding general
flew down to John's position to discuss
the matter with him.
After exam examining the situation,
general white told him he could keep
the spur but was never to advance again
even his outpost line without
express permission from core
cause blue eyes sparkled like those of
a wise and truly tested man who'd long
since realized that humor could
be found in just about anything.
He had seen his share of horror,
his cheeks were rosy and the dueling
scar that crossed one of them and no way
detracted from his Jen rugged
yet gentle old soldier face.
Maybe the scar even enhanced it,
I don't know,
but it sure gave him more character
and provided a good yarn to boot.
In any event.
Colonel Glover,
s Johns was a 49 year old stud.
Colonel Johns was a basics
man and a total soldier.
He taught and insisted that his company
commanders teach things like terrain
appreciation,
the knowledge of which was a basic tool
of a soldier's trade to be able to look
at a piece of ground and appreciate the
slightest differences in the comm tour,
to notice how the ground
unfolds and be able to think.
There's cover over their cover.
The one essential providing protection
from direct enemy fire to recognize a
streamline of gully or treed area as an
avenue of approach through which a unit
could move unseen to understand and
identify the best ground from which to
launch or repel an attack.
Shoot,
scoot and communicate.
The morning battle drill
began with fire and maneuver.
One man firing while his buddy moved
a fire team moving wallets counterpart
fired colonel. John's likened it to a
fighter's bobbing, weaving and jabbing.
We kept the mythical enemy pinned down
while we jabbed our way to close on his
position.
That's covering move by the way.
The colonel was right there with us to
set the example and we did it until we
got it right.
We'd ended up black and blue running,
hating the ground and rolling into firing
position with full field equipment on
is not without pain,
but no one bitched because John's again
and again reinforced the simple equation.
The quicker you get to the ground
and you get your weapon to position,
the sooner you'll be delivering effective
fire on the enemy and the longer
you'll stay alive.
Still,
this truism was just one part of the
overall strive to better your best
philosophy.
That characterized the first,
the w of the 18th under Colonel Johns
and deputy commanding officer couch in
couches words.
It was our policy to encourage
excellence among the soldiers,
particularly in bayonet training,
unarmed combat shooting,
and total physical fitness.
This is what really makes a soldier.
If he masters masters these subjects,
he'll fight.
From my experience in Korea,
I could not have agreed more.
So that's a little opener
from a book called about face,
my favorite book by,
it's written by Colonel David Hackworth,
and he's talking about a guy that was his
commander in the early 1960s Hackworth
had gotten out of the army and then came
back in after a couple of years because
he realized to civilian life was not fun.
And so he came back in and
he got stationed in Germany
and this guy by the name
of colonel glove rest Johns,
who by the way,
he dead Hackworth the dedicates.
He's dedicated the book to him for two
minutes and some other soldiers that he
worked with along the way. But
it's their Glover Johns. He says,
dedicated this book to Glover
Johnson who showed us how to lead.
Mm.
So Glover,
John's outstanding combat leader.
And luckily we can all learn from Glover.
John's not only from what he passes
through Hackworth in Hackworth book,
but also from his own book club rest.
John's wrote his own book called the
Clay Pigeons of St Lo about his push from
Norman d and across France
that Hackworth just referenced.
Now, it's interesting when we go into this
book, the Clay Pigeons, the St Lo, he,
he writes the book in the third person
and he says that it was just easier
for him to write it that way.
So in other words, he's, he doesn't
say, I did this and I did that. He says,
Major Johns did this and major
dog John said something else.
But what's interesting is he said that
one of the reasons he was able to,
one of the reasons that he did that was
because the guy that was commanding in
combat was a battalion
commander and comment was
different from his normal self.
And so we had this combat
John's combat Glover,
John's that was out there leading
things and he had normal John's.
That was the way he lived his normal life.
But it was easier for him to write and
more natural for him to write about this
major John's guy in the third person.
And he also likes it
cause it can gives him,
it gives me the ability to kind of detach
from it and explain what was going on.
So when you hear it,
it's all about major John's instead
of being about me and about I,
but it's, it's him and even though
it's written from the third person,
it is absolutely a first person account
from a battalion commander in combat,
close,
intense combat,
and let's pick it up.
Going to the book,
the Clay Pigeons of St Lo.
Here we go. Sharp ballistic cracks
pounded his ear drum so rapidly.
They seemed like one impossibly
prolonged rifle shot.
He was instantly paralyzed with
overwhelming fright. The radio operator,
Jimmy slumped forward at his feet.
Another man stumbled pass to
fall into the ditch ahead.
Then Newcome cleared the eight foot
hedgerow apparently with one jump,
but the major was too shocked to move.
His stomach knotted
itself into a tight ball.
It jammed against his pounding heart
while his breath stopped completely for an
instant,
then came and Jerky gasps
the hair on his head,
felt as if it were rising
like the hair on a cat's back,
his skin prickled all over.
But the most awful thing was the
cold empty feeling in his guts.
The burst of German machine
gun fire lasted only seconds,
but it seemed like a lifetime before
he could reach up and snatch or grenade
from his pistol belt.
He'd never heard a bullet
crack by inches from his head.
He didn't know they sounded like that.
He thought there was a German with a burp
pistol behind the nearest tree on top
of a hedge row.
He grabbed the pin on the grenade,
but before he could throw it
something made him stop and yell.
Anybody on the other side, he
got a quick answer. Hell yes.
Before he could lower his arm.
The blast of a rifle right
in his lap made him flinch.
He squirmed back even closer
against the hedge row.
As Martin and grim cell went into action,
they'd been at the front all 11 days
since a continuous line had been
established in Normandy. The crack
of bullets was nothing new to them,
almost side by side,
lying flat and the ditch.
They fired methodically across
him and over Jimmy's head.
Mechanically. He checked the pin in
the grenade then still a little dazed,
hooked it back onto his belt harnessed.
He looked at the man who had fallen in
the ditch and now was trying to weekly
push himself up.
It was Lieutenant Sadler,
his face already greenish gray with shock.
He had been hit five or six
times in the head, chest,
and both arms major.
John's knew instinctively that
Sadler was as good as dead.
He called to him to lie,
steal and take it easy.
But the Charlie company commander
was already beyond hearing.
John's felt that he ought to
do something constructive,
something to get their minds off
the tragedy that had just struck,
but it was without
inspiration merely numb.
Hey, you guys yelled grizzle.
Let's Scram Outta here.
That brought the commander out of
the days he had been in ever since.
The deafening burst of enemy fire,
perhaps two minutes before he leaned
forward and shook Jimmy Shoulder. Come on,
Jim.
It's all over now you can get up.
Jimmy didn't move major.
John's shook him again.
Then he saw blood oozing slowly,
thickly, brightly across his own shoe.
Gently. He pulled a Jimmy's
far shoulder, a neat,
clean little bullet hole in the
boy's helmet came into view.
So the major knew that Jimmy was dead.
Something impelled him to pull Jimmy
over until he could look into his face.
The eyes were closed and an odd little
half smile made Jimmy look as if he were
asleep.
Dreaming Pleasant Dreams.
Slowly the major lowered him back to
the ground and for a fleeting instant
watched Jimmy's lifeblood
continued to flow across his shoe.
So
that's his really his
first experience in combat.
And you can see,
obviously it's,
it's a hell of a wake up call.
And the whole book,
the whole book is like this. It's
an, it's an incredible book. The,
the way he describes the battles and
how they're laid out and the way he lays
out his own thoughts and what's
going on. It's just a, it's, it's an,
it's an outstanding book and it's
one of these books where as I had to
consciously say to myself, okay, Jocko,
you cannot read this whole book
on the podcast. We need to,
you know,
people need to read it for themselves.
But the book is that the
description of combat like that,
that opening is phenomenal.
So let's go back to the book now where
that first battle is over and he's having
some thoughts here. We go back
to the book. As he walked,
he couldn't keep his thoughts away from
the hot spot he'd been in a few minutes
before and the lessons he learned
so quickly, but it's such a price.
In little more than an
hour of his first fight,
he lost two company to radio operators
and three other men besides just escaping
death himself. As he thought about the
crack of those machine gun bullets,
his stomach began to score him
again until by a conscious effort.
He forced it to behave.
He couldn't understand why he
hadn't been hit to Jimmy's head.
Had been not more than two feet from
his own Newcomb and the front and Sadler
directly behind him had been hit.
The whole burst must've missed
him by scan inches. He decided,
and he very seriously
thank God for his safety.
At the same time,
he promised never again to risk the
lives of others if he could avoid it.
It was a bitter lesson repeated every
time the eyes of his mind focused on
Jimmy's bright blood oozing over
a shoe or on Sadler. Sudden death.
He looked down at the shoe,
shuttered at the still red stain and
tried to scuff it off on the grass
on his way to the regimental command post,
the major passed a
knocked out Sherman tank.
What distinguished this?
Smoking Brown hoke from others he had
seen that day was the single blackened
claw like hand and forearm that was
thrust out of the turret turret toward the
sky.
The fingers were separate and more
than half curled like the talent of a
striking eagle,
but there's hand was not striking.
It seemed rather to be calling down an
implication on the fate that it let it
die there in agony.
So now he gets to the
regimental commander. Well,
boom, the regimental commander,
what's going on?
I've just been trying to get to you.
John saluted it as he answered,
sir,
we're stuck at the second hedge row and
I had to use my reserve to protect my
flanks.
It doesn't look as if we'll get to the
forge today unless we have better luck
later.
Have many casualties.
I Dunno about the companies yet because
I haven't had any reports from them
except the yells about their
flanks and counter attacks.
But nab was wounded early Sadler is dead,
and I've lost two operators besides
three other men out of my own CP group.
He was still too full of his experience
not to want to tell about it.
The colonel listen sympathetically.
Well, he said when the major was through,
we've got to keep going regardless.
Division wants to get the forge tonight.
So yeah, you just had that rough
day. First Day of combat. Guess what?
We're still going at it.
You know,
one of the things that in that opening
paragraph that I pointed out was you
could see his reaction when
that first fight broke out.
His reaction was sort of overwhelming,
overwhelmed by the whole scenario. But
it's two guys. And what happened is,
and you know he talks about this in the
book, but he had gone on the Normandy,
but he wasn't in charge
of a battalion yet.
He was sort of a back with the regimental
command and then one of the battalion
commanders was out of the fight and I
forget if the battalion commander was
killed or wounded,
but he went and took this battalion
commander's job so he wasn't on the real
front lines until they were starting
to push through France a little bit.
Then it was only a matter of days.
But these,
well I guess it was 11
days cause these guys are,
he said that these other guys had
been on the front lines for 11 days.
So these guys, it's been 11
days. But guess what, there
they start getting shot at,
boom, they're there, they're in the mode,
they're returning fire and you could
see they're returning fire. Really cool.
So close that it scared him.
And that's one of the things that,
you know,
a lot of times I talk about simunition
and training with simunition and how
awesome it is and,
and that's totally true.
And I love training with ammunition and
it really is very beneficial for your
tactical skill level,
but you also absolutely
have to do live fire.
And the reason you have to do live fire,
I mean there's a bunch of reasons
you have to do it. You know,
you have to learn to shoot real bullets
and hit real targets or with your
bullets,
but also guns are loud and you need to
condition yourself to be used to having,
uh, uh, mark 48 machine gun,
four inches, maybe not forced,
but like 16 inches from your head and
your buddy is dumping rounds down range.
And you have to be able to think during
that and not be overwhelmed by it to the
simunition. That's one's an ass. Like how,
what's the difference in loudness
is not even comparable. So is it,
so it's not even really like not gun
shot? No, it's not like a gunshot.
It's not comparable. It's not,
the noise is not comparable.
The noises is less than a cap gun kind of.
Yeah.
Like an air soft gun is loud
and a mark 48 machine gun.
It's really that,
and it's sending little shockwaves.
Every round is like a little shock
that you get. And so that's why,
that's why it is so
important to train live fire.
And it's also important to be comfortable
not only yourself shooting in close
proximity with other people,
but also them shooting near you.
Cause you've got to trust
the guys that are around you.
Now there's standard operating procedures
that there's things that you don't do
that keep it safe, but it's still,
I mean, when somebody makes a bet,
if somebody makes a really bad mistake
and they can walk into your field of fire,
and so you have to be heads up,
but you still have to take shots with
people that are really close to you in a
firefight, by the way.
Well, yeah, in a firefight.
But if you haven't done it
during training, your first,
your first minute in a
firefight is going to be just,
just overwhelmed and you're not
gonna be overwhelmed by enemy fire.
You'd be overwhelmed by your own guy
shooting the mirror and you're going to be
hitting, getting hit by brass
and, and just, it hurts, Hon.
Yeah.
Hot Brass and the,
the links coming out of a mark 48
are like little weapons themselves.
And when they hit the, yeah, we had, uh,
one of our machine gunners was a lefty
and he picked up and started shooting who
he picked up that machine gun and started
shooting lefthanded and that dumps the
brass basically right on your right bicep.
And he had a, he had a bruise on his,
on his right arm that looked like somebody
beat him with a baseball bat in the
arm. That's what a mark 48
ejector port does to you.
It doesn't play around.
So again,
going back to the situation
he's in right now, he's,
he's had all these casualties and they're
like the major says, Hey, yup. Uh,
regardless,
we've got to keep going,
which is w which is the
way war actually is.
So that night, um, he
has a little company,
little huddle with the company
commanders and you know, just to,
just to kind of spell this out, if
you're wondering what this is all about.
So he's got the, he's a
battalion commander, so,
and if he's actually got this written
out in the book, but a Battalion Co,
a battalion in 1944 was about 900 guys,
900 men,
28 officers.
You got three companies.
The three companies are broken
down into three platoons.
Each one of those platoons
has a platoon leader,
but each one of the companies has
a company commander, a captain.
And so that's what he's talking about.
So he,
so those are your kind of your hundred
and 50 men fighting elements are these
companies with three platoons
in them of 50 people each about,
and it's weird because people
always think the military is,
everything's perfectly structured. But
actually this, this changes all the time,
not based on, but based on your
mission, you know, sometimes you,
you might have a platoon that needs
to get plussed up or a company that's
shorter people. So there's no, there's
no consistent, just all the time number.
Let me see what he says. The actual number
that they were supposed to have in a,
in a company at this time was each rifle
company was made up of six officers and
186 men. That's what they
are supposed to have in them.
Now you're going to find out real quick
that they rarely have even close to a
hundred, but that's what they're
supposed to have. So at this point,
he's bringing in these three company
commanders to talk to them about kind of a
plan and also to get a debrief on,
on what happened during the day
and what they're planning to do.
Hat here we go back to the book.
He thought a moment, and this is,
this is, uh, one of the company
commander's name, Lieutenant Ryan.
And he's talking and he says he
thought a moment and then added.
We might make it across the road if we
pour a lot of smoke and mortars into them
and then rush them,
but it'll take. But uh,
but it's getting awfully late to be
beating around in this kind of country.
So trying to figure out how to
move forward. And Lieutenant Ryan.
That was kind of Lieutenant Ryan
suggestion. Let's mortar him,
put a bunch of smoke out and
then we can move, but guess what?
It's getting late and if we're
running around once it gets dark,
it's going to get scary.
Ryan stopped and looked at Kenny.
It was Kenny's turn and Kenny, you're
going to find out is a legit Badass.
Sir.
I only had a few minutes to look things
over before Wendell came along and he
invited me back here to see you,
but that orchard is a terrible place.
No cover anywhere.
Machine guns covering every inch of it.
We lost a lot of men in there
the first time he paused,
but we'll do the best we
can. Well, rough or not,
we're going ahead.
The major stated flatly,
by the way,
Kenny just took over for,
for one of the company commanders
that had been a wounded or killed.
Now they start pushing and all of
a sudden they're pushing forward.
And again,
I have to skip through this book and
I'm trying to highlight the leadership
scenarios or the things that reveal
the way human beings react in hard
situations.
But when you read this book yourself,
you can really follow the tactical
decision making process and also how the
battles went and what happened.
Obviously I can't go through
the whole thing right now,
but at this point they had started
pressing and all of a sudden he sees guys
running away running.
So you know as the company commander,
and he talks about this where he
positions himself and obviously he doesn't
position himself right on
the front with the platoons.
He's back a little bit at this point,
guys start,
he sees guys are running back towards him.
At first he thinks it might be Germans,
he's no, it's Americans, it's his guys.
And here we go back to the book.
That major got to his feet.
He started a crouching run to the left.
He had nearly reached the end of the
field when four or five men yelling,
don't shoot, don't shoot. Piled over
the hedge row. That's separated.
Charlie and Baker companies.
He stopped car being alert
as he lowered his gun.
Wondering what this was all about.
A figure stepped out from the hedge
row and voiced the same question.
What's going on here anyway,
just what's this all about?
It was lieutenant I period.
Arms spread wide to catch the running
men carbines slung over his soldier
shoulder.
The picture of calm.
He caught the leading man by his jacket,
which piled the others up in a
tight little, not the man pound.
Panted Krauts, paratroopers.
They're right behind us.
Run a period, glanced over
the man's shoulder. Unmoved.
Well, now I don't see
any crowds. Just look,
the men looked back.
All they could see were several
Charlie company men standing quietly.
Rifles ready. The leader of the runaways
relaxed then shuttered violently.
I period went on. I don't think
there's any crowds chasing you at all.
Let's just go see about this.
The man tried to pull away
from him, but there were,
he cried.
There were,
I tell they came right over the hedgerow
and shot down right down the whole
squad. They got the sergeant and all
the rest. We're the only ones left.
They nearly got me. Look, he poked a
finger through a hole in his jacket,
but I period,
unimpressed moved in the direction of
Baker company even as the man protested
dragging him along while the
others followed meekly. Well,
I period went on,
let's just go see what captain
Weddell has to say about the Aldis.
He called softly to the men guarding
the company flank, see anything? No Sir.
The answer came back quickly and calmly.
The mortar observer and his little group
of panic stricken men disappeared over
the head dro,
the major new.
He had just seen a wonderful example
of leadership at its very finest.
I period,
quickly,
calmly and efficiently had stopped
what could have been a route.
So one leader steps out
and really what he's doing,
if you think about it, he's detached
because he wasn't in that situation.
Where do you need some Germans came over
and obviously shot at him more close
range, killed a couple of guys, you know,
would've would've wounded this soldier
who got shot through his jacket.
But he just gets, he kind of
gets the guy to detach, hey look,
there's no one there. Calm down. Let's
go have a look. Let's take a step back.
And that kind of calmness prevented
everyone cause cause what can go in the
other direction, right? We can go the
other x. Do you see people running?
That's what happens.
You see people running,
you start running and you know that
that was very interesting in the,
in the, I don't know if you remember
some of those police shootings where,
I remember there's one in New York City
where something like 57 rounds were
fired. It somebody that was
unarmed and everyone's going, why?
Why was everyone shooting? And I'll
tell you what happens is, you know,
for some reason they think you think
somebody has a weapon or a suspect was
going to do something bad and now you've
got five or six people that are holding
a gun on him. Well, when
one's person started shooting,
when people are not attached and when
people are caught up in the moment,
everyone starts pulling
the trigger and it's, it's,
it can be really devastating. It
can be really devastating. Yeah,
so wait,
but when people are used to that kind
of stress and they're calm and they're
detached, one person takes a
shot, you, you, you actually,
instead of just firing yourself,
you actually assess and say, okay,
what is he shooting at? I
need to get cover. So there's,
that's why that training is so important
to get people at a high stress level
and still think through
things and still be detached.
The stress is going to be there,
put it in a box, monitor it,
don't get in it because you're
going to make bad decisions.
You might not make any decisions.
You might just go off of your reactions,
which are, I'm sitting
here with a gun. People are
shooting, I'm going to shoot to.
That's not, I mean it's like how
you say when you're not trained,
you don't have experience in
those types of situations. Like A,
you're the shooting example.
It's,
it's one of those things where you see it
in Jujitsu when you started this exact,
literally the exact same thing where, so
in a shooting situation, one guy shoots,
you hear the gunfire, basically
your brain just says, okay, it's on.
Yeah, it's a 100% let's go
a full speed. 100% it's on,
you can't like gun shots are being fired.
It's not, not on. You got to go 100%.
So in Jujitsu,
when you first start,
you know how like the guys just
going full speed the whole time,
you're in a spot where it's like
you can't move here. You can't,
you're completely trapped right here.
Not some mission necessarily,
but you're trapped and going crazy. You
know, just cause you don't know they,
it's on. It's either to honor, it's
not on. Yeah. So when you're drained,
what you're talking about is an
individual, individual moment.
What I'm talking about, his group, it's
a group think scenario where, you know,
just like it happens when there's a,
uh,
a gunshot and everyone
starts running people.
But the people in the background don't
even know what they're running. Gosh,
I just see people running.
So they're running. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, that's true. Well,
you imagine how amped you are.
You think there's a bad guy
in a dark alley and you're,
you're there with four your
police partners or your or your,
your military partners.
You're looking down now you think there's
a insurgent there and all of a sudden
around cracks off you're,
you're lucky. And there's a,
there's a situation that
happened where there,
where there was an Iraqi soldier that
had an accidental discharge and you know
what that is like we like it
was laced platoon and layoffs,
wave Splatoon was taken down a building
and I was actually outside the building,
you know,
cause we were taking out
multiple buildings but they
were in one building and
all of a sudden crack a couple rounds,
get shot off.
And you know what it was actually,
I'm pretty sure that it was,
I'm pretty sure Andrew Paul,
this is a whole cast of characters.
I'm pretty sure Andrew Paul was at like
the head of the train or close to the
front of the train in inside that they
were inside this building rounds get
fired. And Andrew Paul's
thinking, okay, I think,
I think I remember Andrew Paul telling
me this angel Paul's like, okay,
well we're going to grenade these.
We're going to throw frag grenades into
this next room cause people are shooting
at us.
And it was a guy,
another heads up guy a couple feet back
that knew where the gunfire came from.
And where it came from was
an Iraqi soldier friendly.
Iraqi soldier had cracked
off rounds and accidentally,
accidentally. And you know, luckily
that that guy was a great guy.
I've really heads up, guy
grabbed him, almost killed,
almost choke the shit
out of him right there.
But can you imagine you're clearing a
house where there's suspected and surgeons
and all of a sudden rounds are five. Well
now you're, but this is the discipline.
And the guys knew, okay, the guys didn't
all just freak out and started shooting.
The guys were, you know,
somebody said, hey, somebody
grabbed the person that shot,
hey that was an AAD. Okay, wrap it
back down, wind it down, everyone calm.
You know what I mean?
So there's the difference between guys
who have been trained really well and
when you haven't been through that
country. And again also, luckily that was,
that didn't happen on the second night
of deployment. We were, you know,
further into the deployment
where guys had been through it.
So was just like we just talked about
guys had guys had been through plenty of
firefights at this point. So they weren't
freaked out that there was gunshots.
They were like, okay wait a second,
where is this gun shots coming from?
But that could have gone
really, really nasty. So train,
train realistically. All
right. At this point. And,
and also just like some of the other
books we've read about World War II where
we've got, you know, it's
basically a movement.
It's basically continually moving,
trying to take down targets,
trying to move forward, trying to get
through France, trying to get to Berlin.
That's, that's the situation. And it's
the same thing here. These guys, this,
these battalions and this regimen and the,
basically the whole task
force is trying to move from,
from city to city or town
to town through France.
And that's what's going on here. So
it's, it's a continual series of attack,
dig in, attack, dig in,
attack, dig in. And you know,
you can tell from the title of the
book what they're going for is this,
this final, you know, some
city of St Lo and France.
So at this point there's an attack that
they were getting ready to go on and
he's trying to figure out why it
got canceled and he's talking to,
uh, the commander and he says, I think,
I think you've got farther from
where you started than anyone else.
So he's telling these
standalone major John's,
your battalion went further than
anyone else back to the book. In fact,
I believe that's why division canceled
your attack. If you'd made La Forge,
you would've been way out on a limb and
stood a chance of being caught off major.
John's elated at their comparative success
was thankful that he had not renewed
the attack and perhaps made
another 500 or a thousand yards.
They would have been out front like
clay pigeons for anyone to knock down.
There was the first time he had seen
a practical application of what was
popularly known as the big
picture supposedly concocted
for edification of high
brass and war correspondents,
yet sufficiently vague to cover a
certain amount of error on the ground.
So the reason that I wanted to call
that out is he's admitting that from his
perspective, like why are you stopping
my attack? And at this point they had,
they'd gotten bogged down and
then they were ready to go again.
Then they got back down and now they were
ready to go and they get told to stop.
And so his first reaction, kind of,
what do you wait, why are we stopping?
We've actually got some
momentum right now.
And then he finds out that from the big
picture, the reason you're not attacking,
just cause you're too far out ahead of
everyone. If you get go any further,
you might get surrounded and cut off.
Now this is a situation
where understanding why,
why is so helpful and especially if
you push that all the way down to the
frontline troops and to the frontline
leadership that's out there thinking, Hey,
we finally made some some offensive
progress and we can move and we can really
take it to the enemy and now you're
telling us to stop what is going on.
The headquarters is stupid.
They don't get it.
They don't understand that
actually they do understand,
but they need to do a better
job of explaining why. So the,
so let the people know.
All right,
moving on to this next section here.
He's checking out kind of
his line now that they're,
now that they're dug in a little
bit, he'd gone to regiment. You know,
it's really easy to forget that these
guys, and I talk about this a bit,
but the best type of communications
that they have is when they actually run
wires between different, between
regiment, between battalions,
between the companies.
They try and runs wires because the
radios are fairly temperamental on whether
they work or not. So they
use radios, a backup,
but the primary communication
is is running a wire and
he had just gone back to
regiment to meet face to face cause
me fake meeting face to face is very
important and you know he just comes
back up and he asks one of the company
commander, actually I think it
was his, his ops officer Newcomb.
He says,
Hey,
any news and new has
ops officer says Nope,
everything's quiet as a church.
The s three looked at the battalion
commander and the starlight and grinned as
he went on. Now major, you don't have to
concern yourself with everything up here.
You just leave the details to us.
We're used to looking after them.
So a little bit of decentralized command.
Don't worry about a boss. We got this.
We're going to be all right
now.
Next day rolls around and here we go.
Back to the book around 1,000 the Germans
shelled the battalion heavily but they
didn't follow up.
Follow this up with an attack by 1100 the
wounded had all been evacuated and the
wire lines had been
relayed to the regimen.
The major instructed Grizzle to collect
all five company commanders and meet him
as soon as possible at the crossroads
of the edge of the woods from which they
had first attacked.
It was only a little way
from the regimental command
posts to the edge of the
woods.
He got there well before the others
when they came up a few minutes later,
he knew he missed Newcomb before he caught
the meaning of their odd mode manner.
Grim sells set face have given him a hint.
As the s two step forward saluted very
stiffly and said with visible effort to
keep his emotions under control. Sir, I
must report that captain Newcomb is dead.
The others look silently at the
ground and tears began to stream down.
The gentle grim sells face.
The news struck the major with the force
of a physical blow of all the fine men
he had met since taking
command of the battalion.
Newcomb had been one of the very best.
He was quick,
willing and intelligent wise,
far beyond his 24 25 years.
He also stared at the ground for a moment
and then ask quietly how did it happen?
Ryan spoke up, same sniper,
same place as the doc,
so a doc had been killed
earlier by a sniper.
One of my men wore nuke to stay
out of that gap and the hedge row,
but he took the steel part of his
helmet off and sat down on it.
Right Square in the gap itself.
The sergeant who thought the captain
must have gone nuts all of a sudden was
coming after him to drag him away,
but too late the sniper got
him right in the temple.
John's felt numb inside.
Okay,
but to dwell on his sorrow wouldn't help.
Nodding.
Solemnly he leveled his
finger at Captain Weddell.
You are now lagoon red three but you
will retain command of your company until
we complete the move into these woods.
Weddle equally grave replied.
Yes sir.
I have a little news to
Lieutenant Chadwick got half
his helmet knocked off by a
burp gun during all that
shooting a while ago.
He caught either a part of his helmet or
some of the slugs in his arm. He's out,
but he isn't hurt badly.
He'll be back.
Major John's who'd never met
Chadwick merely nodded again.
It didn't hurt so much when you
didn't know the man. Furthermore,
a wound regardless of its severity,
lack the awful finality of death.
Chadwick's temporary loss
meant one less officer,
whereas new comes death
left a hole in his heart.
Although he knew weddell
would probably be good.
S three to Newcomb in the four
short days he had known him,
had become a friend.
Grim sill had moved a little away from
the others. He was leaning against a tree.
His head down in the curve of his arms.
Saab shaking his body.
He a newcomer to become close friends
for years and had worked together daily.
The major spoke to Captain Menzer,
the headquarters company commander.
See the Lieutenant Grimsey is pulled off
somewhere where it's quiet and give it
a chance to lie down and get some rest.
If he objects, tell them it's an order.
I don't want to see him around anymore.
Today.
Yeah.
Mansour, small and Dapper.
Saluted sharply. Yes sir.
I'll look after George.
All right.
Okay.
These guys are taking casualties at
just an incredible amount and you know,
you see a couple things in
here that we've heard before.
You know,
you see
the major realizing that
that gristle he's done,
he needs a break and you know,
he says get them off the line,
get him somewhere.
He can take a break.
And you also see these guys filling
billets and just getting promoted.
You know,
battlefield promoted,
the guy was all one of the company
commanders Weddle he becomes the,
he becomes the operations
officer. Boom on the spot. It's,
it's
really,
you can see why this book was
when a hack words favorite books.
Hmm.
So now they're, they're holed up for a
while and here we go back to the book,
10 days,
drag by wall.
The battalion sat in Boyda breadwinner
if the days where sometimes doll,
they were rarely uneventful.
Men were wounded or killed nearly every
day by artillery mortars or the fire
from self prepaid.
It propelled 88 that could move unseen
into positions from which they could fire
into the tops of trees of the Blah and
then pull back before the artillery men
could bring fire on them.
Those casualties were bad enough,
but they were to be expected.
There was one incident that the battalion
commander thought they could have got
along very nicely without regimen and
directed that the battalions erect Barb
wire along their whole front,
which they did cheerfully,
but when a truck load of anti
personnel mines came down,
the major looked at them with misgivings.
Those things were as dangerous to the
people who laid them as those as they work
to the enemy. He thought so. He
supervised the mind lane carefully,
meticulously noting the location of
each mine on a large scale sketch of the
area being mined.
The day after all the mines were laid,
he heard the flat multiple muffled
roar of a landmine at once.
He ran toward the sound.
He got there with the aid men to
watch with sorrow and anger while they
evacuated. Three men from the
middle of their own mind field.
One of them was dead.
The last litter carried our period
who badly hit in the legs with several
fragments,
did not know how severely he was hurt.
The other wounded men unconscious was
being placed on the medical jeep when
still another literal came around the
corner of the little farm house that stood
on the edge of the woods. The man
on this litter had his eyes closed,
his face twisting horribly.
He jerked over.
He jerked all over bringing
his legs up so hard.
The aid men had to hold
them down on the litter.
The major looking at the man and wonder,
asked, what's the matter with him?
The eight men were
contemptuous. Ah, said one.
This guy never got hit by nothing.
He was in a whole 50 yards
from where it happened,
but he started screaming and yelling
and carrying on something awful.
We thought he was hit, but he ain't
got a hole in him. He was like this.
When we got to him,
John's realized he had just seen his
first case of neuro psychosis commonly
called combat exhaustion or c II.
It wasn't the only one he was to see.
So you got,
well I guess that's is that friendly fire
friendly fire when you hit one of your
own landmines
night
mirror
now.
And also that you start seeing some,
some psychological damage to guys on the,
on the front line.
And you know, that guy's not going
to be any good. He can't fight.
He's literally screaming and jerking
around. They have to hold him down.
All right,
now the battalion is going to move
in and take over a whole area,
um, from the third armored division
and it's in moving into this area.
It's got 300 replacements coming
in. So, so think about that.
Battalion supposed to be 900 people
and they're getting 300 replacements.
So that tells you, and again,
I am breezing, I'm skipping,
I'm not even breathing,
I'm not breezing through.
I'm skipping so much of the
fighting and combat in this book,
but it's just going on continuously.
And at this point they're going in,
they have, they already have
300 replacements. So they've,
they've had 300 people,
uh, you know, taken out or, or
either either wounded or killed.
So at this point,
Lieutenant Ryan's company is on a
patrol and they're going to go set up an
outpost into some pretty,
pretty rough area.
And as the patrols out there,
here we go.
Then came the first shots from the patrol.
They were going in well and it looked
for a few seconds as if Ryan was going to
get to his outpost.
But a flare of three red star clusters
floated up from the German lines and all
hell broke loose again.
Every kraut gun that had been used
to help stop the third armored plus,
probably a few that had come in late,
opened up on about 150 yards of a,
of the able company front.
It was concentrated thunderous murder,
such as no one in the
battalion had ever seen before.
Ryan's line was a massive saving leaping
flame that looked as if it were fed
from below rather than from
an inconceivable torrent
of shells that came on and
on and on.
The barrage switch suddenly from the
company to the Battalion Command Post area
itself,
the battalion commander and his staff
hearing the first wine to the shells dived
for the new command post hole where they
huddled walk while the walls shuttered
and dirt rain down from the roof.
Concussion blew out the candles,
but nobody was hurt.
The German gunners switch to c
company for a few rounds then right,
went right back to their
prime target able company.
Yeah.
While they were pounding Kenny's company,
a single short call came in over
the 300 which is their radio able.
Six is clipped.
That meant Ryan had been hit,
but there were no details.
20 minutes after that pretty red star
cluster went up. All was quiet again,
except for some moans and cries for medics
that floated back from able company,
but at least know Germany.
Infantry had come in under fire
in the 20 in that 20 minutes,
the company lost 54 men
plus it's company commander.
Almost every man in the patrol had been
caught above ground and was killed or
wounded while most of the other casualties
came from tree and hedge row bursts
that sent fragments down into the holes.
The men of the command post group gathered
around the whole silently watch the
parade of walking wounded that filed
slowly by on the way to the aid station.
Occasionally a man
would stumble or waiver,
whereupon a messenger or wire
man would jump to help him.
Every aid man and litter in the battalion
was already up at the abl line and the
first litters were not far
behind the walking wounded.
Some of the victims moaned and a
few cried out a little now and then,
but most were very quiet.
John's was glad he could not
see their faces in the dark.
The last litter went by with no word
from Ryan Johnson's beginning to hope he
hadn't been hurt badly.
When four men loomed out of the darkness,
each carrying a corner of a blanket.
Ryan was half sitting,
half lying in the makeshift litter,
gritting his teeth at the pain of
the wounds in an arm and a leg.
They laid the blanket down gently in
front of the major who stripped off his
coat and laid it over.
The company. Commander
Ryan managed to work up a feeble grin.
Okay?
It didn't work too good,
did it boss?
That's
know when you're the company,
when you're the battalion commander and
you come up with a plan with the company
commander and you think
you've everything right and
you lose 54 guys in a
company in 20 minutes
and your company commander comes
back and says, it didn't go too good,
did it boss to heavy weight.
Now they do end up pushing forward.
They get some ground and
okay,
he's out checking and you're gonna,
you're gonna find this out.
And he talks about it,
but he goes forward to find out what's
going on and make sure the guys see him.
And at one point he's checking an outpost,
a little outpost where they're guarding
this certain area and all the guys in
the group are focused on a tank on old
burned out tank that's out there in front
of him and he comes up to them
and here we go. Back to the book.
John's pointed to the corner.
Does it take all three of you to watch
that tank while the whole German army
could crawl up to within 10
feet of you without knowing it?
The sergeants mouth dropped open.
God Major.
I never even thought about it after
they shot at us from the tank last time.
Well,
you better damn straight start
thinking about your flanks if you want.
If you want to end up
being able to think at all.
I wouldn't give a damn if they knocked
all three. You stupid bastards out.
But if they got you,
they'd have a good chance of getting
into the middle of your company and I
wouldn't like that. Now.
Damn you start thinking
again. You know what? He's detached.
Those guys just got shot
at from those 10 that tank.
They're not worried about their flank.
They're worried about that tank.
Another sniper being in there, another
machine gunner sneaking up into it,
so he's detached. He
rolls up and sees, Hey,
I see that you're focused on the tank, but
you can't. You've got to keep thinking.
Yeah.
Going back to the book, orders came
down during the night directing lagoon.
Red Major John's first battalion of the
hundred and 15th Infantry Regiment would
relieve lemon read by
midnight of the following day,
lemon was code named for the hundred
and 16th who's read first battalion was
holding the line to the
left of where lagoon read.
It hopped off nearly three weeks before,
so they're growing up to relieve and and
hold the line they're going up to do,
to take positions and hold them.
Meeting the commander of this,
of this group that they're taking
the place of back to the book,
the big commander introducing himself,
shook hands all around, they need,
took a deep breath and started in on
a careful detailed briefing fellows.
He said,
this is a hot spot.
I know you've all been in
hot lots of them before,
but please take my word for it.
This one is really hot.
He paused and looked at the as if to make
sure they were going to take his word
for it.
Then he went on.
We've got Nazi paratroopers on
the other side of the hedge rows.
They're the best that Hitler has and they
know it. They don't give us much rest.
We don't give them any.
Okay,
we have casualties every day,
so please do your best not to cause
any more than we have to take. Anyway.
My boys had been here for two weeks
now and they're getting right touchy.
So if any of you get snapped that
don't take, don't pay attention to it,
just go on and they'll get over it.
So this guys guys are pretty
burnt out at this point
and they do this,
they do this turnover
and he goes out and, and again, the
turnover happens, there's more combat,
there's more casualties. And
then he's going out, but they'd,
things settled down and he's going
out to check the line. And here we go.
Back to the book as Usual Major.
John's asked a number of men
how they were getting along.
He got one answer that surprised him and
sergeant said, Welser, everything's okay.
It's a tough spot.
But I figured where as good as any other
outfit to hold it down and somebody's
got to do it. But I sure wish the major
would get around and see us more often.
Does the men a world of good to
see you down here in the lines?
The major who had fought,
he was getting around about as often
as any battalion commander should were
seriously concerned because this
sergeant didn't seem to think so.
Instead of being annoyed,
he was pleased that the man
had the uncommon guts to
say what he thought whether
or not he was right.
So there you go.
Battalion commander instead of getting
all mad that this sergeant says something,
he's actually thankful he answered.
Okay Sarge,
you'll see me around a lot more in the
future. The sergeant saluted sharply,
whereupon stone.
This is new company commander stone
and the major went on stone trying to
stammer out and apology for the
Brash Sergeant Johns. Cut Him off,
but not before stone had volunteered the
statement that he himself thought the
major got around more than any other
battalion commander. He never seen
the fact that stone had not seen petty
battalion commanders did not escape Johns
who smiled to himself as the company
commander lapsed into an embarrassed
silence.
On the way back to battalion.
You reviewed his own approach
to the problem of leadership.
He knew that he must prove himself,
especially his courage to every man in
the outfit if he expected to get the
maximum from them.
He felt that he had done so fairly
effectively as far as seed company was
concerned because he stayed with them
that night for the counter attack,
the that had threatened their left flank.
Also,
his personal intelligence service told
him that a company had approved the
little battle he and grim Sul and Martin
had had with a machine that it killed
Jimmy and Sadler.
So he's got his own.
You like notice that his
personal intelligence service,
that means he's got, I,
I've talked about this before,
where you got your own guys that
are telling you what's going on.
So his own little guys had
told them that a company,
they respected him and they knew he was
going to get after it back to the book,
but it was apparent that this was going
to be a company by company proposition.
Baker company didn't seem to be impressed.
He'd have to do something about that.
Now
this is just another thing
about leadership there.
He's on a field phone and again I talked
about how they put these wires in and
he's on a field phone and he gets done
making something happen on the field
phone to puts down the phone on the table.
The phone rang before
anyone could say anything.
John's picked it up barking red six.
That's his call side.
The operators voice came through
clearly. Are you finished? Yes, I am.
He slammed it back on the table
where it all shook his head.
You forgot to ring off.
Major Sergeant Wilson gives the operators
hell if they don't make sure the lines
are clear. Sergeant Wilson was
the acting communications officer.
The original man had been killed
and Wilson was doing a fine job.
He'd been in for a
commission for quite a while.
John's picked up the phone and
twisted the crank on the leather case.
The operator answered instantly.
Yes sir. What's your name?
Operator private Henderson, sir.
The voice was a little uncertain.
Okay. Private Henderson, you keep doing
your job the way you're supposed to.
Don't mind me if I snap at you once
in a while. I'm sorry. He finished.
He started to lay the phone down,
smiled, picked it up and added, finished.
So again, you can see he's a
guy that doesn't get all crazy.
When, when you know, when
people come to him and say, Hey,
you're supposed to sign off the line.
I got to keep these lines open.
You're not signing off the line.
Are you done?
You see EGOMANIAC leaders do that.
Get crazy on stupid stuff.
They're not following their own rules.
Now talking about this network,
uh,
talking about these communications
here we go back to look this,
this network of communications enabled
three men to keep accurate minute by
minute track of all that was
going over on the entire front,
covered by nearly 600
men from this one spot.
They could direct the lives of all those
men actors in the most thrilling and
awful drama of all time.
So the way that they're doing this,
and I should have explained this earlier,
is you have the,
the battalion commander and he has a
small staff of people that stay with him.
Most of the time his operations
officer has communications officer,
his intelligence officer. And what they
do is when they get to certain positions,
they find a command post, a CP.
And when they're in the field,
what they do is they dig a big giant
foxhole and they make it as good as they
can that they put logs over the top of it.
They put dirt on top of that or sand bags
or something. So they're pretty, they,
they're trying to get pretty secure in
there from overhead artillery attacks.
And then they run wires out to set
up communications with all these,
all the company commanders who have their
own little command posts and obviously
this thing isn't permanent because it
has to be mobile because tomorrow night,
the next night we might move another
thousand yards or 500 yards and then that
that foxhole that we'd row Doug
isn't doing us any good anymore,
but from this little command
post that they set up there,
they're running this whole show.
Now he talks about his decision
making here back to the book.
If he made a wrong decision,
he could cause men to lose,
lose their lives needlessly
or if he was clever or lucky,
he might by moving a single squad or
platoon or calling for fire support,
defeat the enemy and gain additional
glory for the unit all without moving from
his communications.
When in a defensive position such as this.
Then he's talking to her about like some
of that drama that happens back to the
book.
A single rifle shot could mean the death
of a company commander or it could mean
nothing.
A mortar round might wipe out an outpost
and lay a company open to a surprise
attack, or it might only kick
up a little dust and scar.
A few trees,
volley of artillery fire could come
through the roof over their heads or it
could burst harmlessly
in the fields outside.
A burst of fire from the orchard could
mean another pig because they had killed
some pigs that they thought were
enemy or a full scale German attack.
Each sound built up a certain amount of
suspense to greater or lesser degree.
The ring of the phone itself built the
tension higher and higher until the first
words that came in would perhaps screw
it even tighter or dispel it entirely.
So that's the life that they're living
and just high pressure all the time.
But you know,
you hear a massive explosion and this is
the same thing I think Lafe was talking
about on the podcast. You
know, you'd hear an explosion,
you have no idea what it is.
You don't know if it's friendly,
you don't know if it's a
tank round being fired.
You don't know if it's an IED going off.
You don't know if it's a a mortar
round impact, you can't, it maybe,
maybe these guys got to a point
where they can tell the difference.
But I'll tell you what,
you get in an urban combat and there's,
the sound is refracting
off all the buildings.
It's hard to tell where it came from and
it's definitely hard to tell what it is.
And by the way,
the artillery rounds that hit
our water's being used as ids.
So you don't know what it is.
It's really hard to tell.
But it was weird too in, in, in
Ramadi, there was constantly on fire.
Like you, when you went
outside, you just hear bonded.
He was always out there, you
know, even if it was even,
it was on the other side of
the city. I mean you, you can,
maybe not the other side of the city,
but if it was in downtown Ramadi and
we were back at our base, you know,
we'd go up on the rooftop of my building
and sit there and you could just
tracers all night, you know, the
marines down in the government center,
we're getting attacked for the 14th
night in a row, you know, the outpost,
the, the army soldiers or camp
Corregidor was getting mortared. I mean,
it was just constant Lee happening.
So what was it where you,
if it's closer, that's when it's the
concern or context in general or, no,
just the, yeah, this, the
overall context for us.
For me it was like,
okay, you know, you just,
you just knew that there was constant
fighting going on or something was going
on. And yeah, I mean obviously
if it was closer than the,
the louder it is and the closer it is,
the more of a concern it because certain,
yeah, he talks about, again, this is a
subject we hear about all the time. Uh,
the German mortars and gunners must've
registered too because they had the exact
range of every foot of hedgerow held
by the battalion on the 10th of July.
They covered almost every
foot of the hedge row.
That's sort of gunnery was rough on the
men they never knew in the first round
would fall, but once it had
splattered with its flat crash,
they all knew that six or maybe a dozen
more were coming each one a little
further up or down the hedge row.
When you heard that first one,
you pulled the bottom of your fox hole
right up to your belly and prayed.
When you heard the second one, you knew
whether or not they were coming your way.
If they were coming towards you,
it got right rough.
Each round was a little closer and they
were so damned deliberate about it that
the waiting was worth worst than
the crash of the shell itself.
You laid there and counted the seconds
between the shells until you knew that
the next one was yours.
The 20 seconds or so was the longest one
in the world because you never knew if
you were safe until the shell hit.
It could hit anywhere outside your whole,
even a matter of inches,
and you're okay if it
hit in the hole with you,
you'd never know it.
Of course,
actually only a few shells ever
made direct hits on Fox holes,
but some did and nearly every man had
seen a fox hole that had been hit.
There was always the little tail fin
section left on the surface and after the
litter bearers had come and gone,
there was only a pool of dark muck to
show that somebody had been in the hole.
It happened twice that day.
So
this one you can, I don't know if
you quite followed what's happening.
These guys are in a hedge row. So when
they're in a linear position, right,
and the way you work mortars is you make
small adjustments on them and and the
way that you fire it targets when you
don't know what the distance is you,
you put the first one is
going to be long and then you,
you adjust a lot shorter. So then you
come back and it's called bracketing.
So you know you might come back
five clicks and then that was,
now you're now you hit in front
of the target, now you go back,
now you go forward again, four clicks,
it hits a little behind the target.
Now you come back three, two, one
and then boom, you hit your target.
So on the mortar thing,
there's like the actual tool that kind
of yeah, you're adjusting the elevation.
Yes. Up and down, a little dial.
It's going up and down to to fire.
At what angle? You want
to find that? Yeah.
So what you do is when you shoot a mortar,
you, you're the first one, you go long,
the second one you estimate short,
and then you basically can split
the difference between those two.
I'm going to be pretty close
and like you work with uh,
a legit mortar team and the third
round is going to be spot on.
But what he's saying here is the Germans,
they already knew the exact
settings for where to put,
oh, we see movement at this part of
the head road. They don't need to take,
they just go to their
predesignated settings. They
can put a round right on that.
So they kind of figured it out beforehand
and figured out beforehand they know
the exact cause of what you, what'd you
have to, you know the distance? Yeah.
You know the distance that the
mortar shoots at a certain elevation.
But what they don't know is if you're
trying to shoot at something that you
don't know exactly where it is, well
then you have to estimate the distance,
which is a little bit challenging to
do. Now. A good sniper or a good mortar,
men are going to be pretty
close. You know, snipers know
that, hey, this thing Vic,
get it down to really,
you know how many meters it is and
same thing with a good mortar man,
but even that,
you know when you're talking about
a far distance of 800,000 meters,
you might be off by 50 meters and that's,
you know,
being off by 50 meters with
a mortar is a big distance.
Not going to kill the target
that you're trying to hit.
But with these Germans at this point,
they already have everything
measured and dial.
They have a range card is what we call it.
Arrange card means like I know exactly
I'm, when you set up in a position,
you could have your range finder and you
find out what the range and distance of
everything they were looking at.
So you know exactly how far it is.
You can dial in your scope. Boom, oh,
I see somebody over at that corner of
that building that's 832 meters. Boom,
crack. Remember the game battleship.
Remember that? I do remember that.
They'll have a ship. Yeah. It's
like you can't see it, but you,
and you're trying to figure it out a
little bit. It is your, you're basically,
your first round is going to be a
little bit, if you hit something,
then you got to adjust those.
Yeah. So what the Germans,
like I said,
the Germans had these things preregistered
and then what they would do is they
would just drop,
they would just hit the whole hedge row.
They go right down the life.
And these guys knew that
once the first round goes,
it's either going to be moving away from
me on the hydro or toward me. Oh yeah.
Yeah. And so can you imagine the, the
damn pressure when you're sitting there,
that first round goes,
and now the next round,
where's it gonna be further away from me?
Meaning the Germans are going to die,
are dialing away from me, right? Or
are they dialing towards me? Yeah.
And then how many rounds are they going
to go? Because if they do enough rounds,
you're, you're going to be all right.
You're, you're not there. The game.
That's exactly what the Hala and what's
interesting is those, like he said,
if the, if the mortar hits outside
of your foxhole by an inch,
you're probably going to be okay because
the mortar blast goes up and out when
it hits the ground. If it hits
in your foxhole, your dead,
and so there's this, this kind of
randomness that you're dealing with.
All right.
Going back to the book a little after
the after 1700 general Gearhart came
striding through the trees
behind the company post hole.
He came on serious business that
of giving orders for an attack.
If he carried them by himself,
they were important gentlemen.
He said with the edge to his
voice that was impressive.
The division attacks tomorrow
at zero 600 all along the line.
This is the drive for St Lo.
There were a few details of Italians
would attack as the general ad set at zero
600 the first battalion would advance
into southwesterly direction with the
village of Bel Fontaine
as its initial objective.
That was about all of them
was to it except for the
usual information concerning
artillery support supplies,
location of regimental command post
and that sort of thing. So pretty
pretty broad orders like, hey,
this is what we're going to do.
We're an attack tomorrow,
zero 600 the mission is to get St Lo
hmm
back to the book.
By the time the order got down to
the platoon leaders in their part,
their part was pretty simple. All Day
in turn had to say was, all right gang,
let's take the next hedge row.
When the company commanders had gone,
the staff discussed the plan of attack.
The question bothering John's most of
all was where to put the advanced command
post group. He wanted to hold
casualties to the barest minimum,
yet he wanted to be as
far forward as possible.
So he's talking about where should he
actually positioned himself and his small
team of battalion staff.
Where should they position themselves?
It's funny too because when we
talk about battalion staffing,
are you talking about,
I don't know,
a battalion staff can be pretty
big when you're in a big battalion,
but this is not a big group.
This small group especially
because they've taken so
many casualties back to the
book. There were a number of good
reasons for this in the first place.
Keeping the command group close to the
companies made a lot of difference in
communications,
particularly in this close wooded country.
A clump of heavy trees are a high hydro
could spell the margin between having
contact and not having it.
That was of supreme importance.
Second,
if you had,
and this is why I was talking
about keeping the plan
simple cause when you start
getting split up from people and you
can't maintain communications with them,
the difference between not
having communication and
having communications is is
night and day. It's disaster and
success. It's victory and defeat.
[inaudible] back to the book.
Second, if he had to move a Bhag,
if he had to move to a bog down
company or to any trouble spot,
he wanted to have the shortest
possible distance to go.
So he wants to be close enough
to have good communication.
So he also wants to be close enough
that if something's going wrong,
he can get there and make things happen.
Third,
the group couldn't afford to stay far
behind in any event because they fully
expected the German paratroopers
to close in around them.
As soon as they started to advance.
If the command post group,
we're too far from the rifle companies,
it would have a good chance of getting
caught off and destroyed or captured.
Then there was always the consideration
that the men like to know that the old
man was not far behind and to see him
once in a while when the stuff was flying
around.
So these are things he's considering.
They're getting ready, you know, it's
now getting closer to the attack.
Back to the book, the staff was
uneasy. They didn't want to turn in.
They couldn't say why there had
been other nights like this.
They all sensed that everyone
shared their own nameless fears.
Now they start their movement.
Suddenly a terrific firing broke out
every German cannon mortar rifle and
machine gun that fired around
that day cut loose simultaneously.
The sound of mortars
coughing on the German side,
blended with the scream
of incoming shells,
grim Salon Hoffman slid down the steps
the whole before the first round is hit,
the phone rang major,
John's grabbed it.
Red Six Charlie six or we're catching
hell down here with mortars and artillery.
I think the, I think there's enemy
infantry coming in under the fire.
So the idea is cover and move you.
You do this as an infantry
platoon or company or a battalion.
You put suppressive fire.
So you start launching mortars at your
enemy and then while they're all taking
cover you advance. And so that's
what he's talking about. He says,
I think there's enemy infantry coming
in under the fire stone broke in
the operator having wisely since the
crisis and cut them into the circuit.
So the other company commander now
tunes in same here, major only.
I know there's infantry coming in.
They're already in the road with us,
so they're just about to get some,
his voice and manner were normally
extremely quiet and easy going.
Now his tone was strident with urgency.
Had it been anyone but Julian
stolen the major might fought it,
showed near panic, okayed the both of
you. He answered as calmly as he could.
Stuff's coming in here to
fight him and keep me informed.
Okay.
Major John's doesn't get excited
about stuff very often. He says, oh,
you're attack. Cool. Fight
him. Keep me informed.
That's how you eat. Yeah. Now
at some point,
all the wires that I talked about that
were so important for communication,
the crowd back at the aid station,
they had a cat and the captured a guy
cried Weddle suddenly he must have been
part of patrol that came through
and caught all our wires. Hell,
there haven't been enough shells
to failing falling to cut them.
All the smart bastards. They even
knew when we checked radios as well.
So these guys set,
a small group of Germans went through the
lines are probably right after a radio
check caught all the wires.
Yeah,
that's, that's how you kick
off a, uh, an attack, right?
You screw up their communications.
Now at this point they are,
this is turning bad,
real bad. And, and this is, again,
there's so much great information in here
and so such good documentation of way
this combat takes place.
But suffice it to say at this point,
I'm skipping forward. They are getting
really crushed. They got mass casualties.
They are there when they advance.
So imagine this,
remember I talked about the Germans know
exactly where they're mortars are going
to hit.
Well the Americans will storm forward
and fight harder and get to another hedge
row when they get to this new
hedge row where the Germans were,
where they just beat the
Germans out of there.
The Germans have that hedge
row dialed as well. So,
so now as soon as they get positioned,
they started getting immediate
effective fire from mortar.
So this is a total nightmare
and that's what's happening.
And at this point they're
completely bogged down.
And this might be, you don't get to
hear a story like this very often.
So the regimental executive Colonel Smith,
Lieutenant Colonel Smith shows up.
So above the chain of command of the
battalion is the regiment and the senior
person in the regiment is the kernel,
the regimental commander,
and this is his executive.
The person that one down from the
regimental commander is this guy,
Lieutenant Lieutenant Colonel Smith,
and he shows up and here's what he says,
what's the matter? John's, why
aren't you getting anywhere?
Smith gasped and this gasp because
he's running into this position,
the major point to the bloody trail,
to the dead men,
to the shells that were savaging the
trees and finally in the direction of the
nearby front from which came the
plotting sound of mortar fire,
his eyes were lacking,
their usual snapped and he answered
[inaudible] they're too tough.
Smith blinked several times.
He was obviously trying to think of
something to say something that would
inspire this listless battalion
commander to new effort. Well,
he finally brought out, you got to get
going right away. Regimen has got to move.
You just got to get going.
John's shook his head.
He wasn't having any,
not today was all he would say.
So we're talking mentally
defeated at this point,
and even the,
the regimental commander coming in,
or the regimental executive
commander coming in telling him,
hey, you got to move. You just got to
go. Which is that, that encouragement,
this reminds me of,
of in Jujitsu tournaments,
you ever seen your coach saying like,
you got to get on top,
you got to do something. I've got to get
out of there. Yeah, that doesn't help me.
So that's what he's saying. Hey you, you
just got to go. I'm getting mortared.
My guys are getting mowed
down. I'm not, I can't do it.
So back to the book then.
For some reason,
both men looked up the hedge row
toward the rear colonel McDaniel,
the new division chief of
staff was striding toward
them, oblivious of the fire.
Just as he reached the command post,
a volley of four rounds screamed in
the field just beyond the headrow.
The concussion tumbled them into
the hole with the major and Smith.
But MCDANIEL did not lose his natural
dignity. And he was smiling as he said,
Hello John's Smith,
how are we doing now?
We got a leader coming in that's very
calm and very cool and just got blasted
into their whole, by the way, and he looks
up smiles and says, how are we doing?
John's made an effort to perk up a bit,
but as voice lacked conviction or forces,
he told McDaniel all about the situation.
The chief of staff survey the scene,
weighing it all very carefully. It'd
be before he answered, when he did,
his tone was serious
and he was not smiling.
John's when you were on maneuvers in
Louisiana or at Vmi and while you were
studying at Leavenworth,
you saw situations where units had to be
sacrificed knowingly in order to get a
job done, didn't you? The
battalion commander nodded.
When you saw those things, you probably
never thought very much about them.
Just accepted them as a matter of course
in war, didn't you? The major nodded.
Again,
you never stopped to think probably that
there might come a time when you and
your unit would be the one that had to
be sacrificed to enable the parent unit
to accomplish its mission.
The majors eyes were opening
wider as he shook his head. Well,
I don't know for sure,
but maybe this is that time.
I do know that this is the highest ground
on the core front and the key to the
entire defense is St Lo core
express expects us to break
it and we think you are
the man to do the job at whatever cost.
Now don't let us down
without another word.
He got to his feet and
walked back the way had come.
The regimental executive tagged after him.
John's watched them go.
Suddenly he remembered that the general,
what the general had said to him
the day before, I'm counting on you.
He turned to Weddell who would watch
this little drama with detached interest.
Leroy, the major said is he squared his
shoulders and pointed to the sinking son.
Take a damn good look at that Sun old
boy cause it's probably the last time any
of us will ever see it.
Let's go.
John's never knew later just what he
did the rest of that afternoon and early
evening.
Can you remembered moving
around the command post
forward again and he knew that
he had needled the company commanders
unmercifully threatening them myrtle with
relief of their commands,
begging, pleading,
anything he could think of that would
work with that individual. At that moment,
he found that there was a comparatively
weak spot in the German lines.
Opposite Baker again,
he badgered Martin into persuading the
artillery to give them all the fire that
he could hit that spot at one time.
That meant a lot of guns when they all
fired three rounds as fast as the gunners
could load them.
A hundred yards of German held hedge
row went up in flame and smoke and dust
again.
Most of Baker companies streamed across
the field and into the gap blasted by
the artillery that took the heart out of
the paratroopers and the paratroopers.
He talking about our German paratroopers
who began to fall back all along the
line.
It was no route.
The Germans retired from their flanking
threat baker post having gained a place
in their main line, but they fell back
slowly fighting every foot of the way.
The tenacious paratrooper slowed the
weakness the weekend battalion again,
but they could not stop it entirely.
The company commanders and the platoon
leaders together with the battalion CEO
had thrown off their apathy,
taken a second wind,
and we're not to be denied at dark thanks
to the inspired leadership that had
been provided in a few short
minutes by Colonel Mcdaniel.
The German line was broken beyond repair.
Battered American battalion
had made 500 bloody yards
as dusk faded into darkness.
That firing began to diminish only
to flare briefly again on the left.
Then it died away into silence.
Kenny called in.
Kenny called in to say there had been a
light counter attack on the left flank.
He had easily kicked it off.
The major did not ask for
permission to halt the advance.
He gave orders to dig
in for the night after.
He was sure the companies had
close contact on their flanks.
So there you go.
That
that's just an amazing account
of not only of leadership,
but if what leadership was capable of.
I mean, John's was pretty much done.
He's literally saying, not
today. They're too tough
in the way that make Danial convinces
him and explains to him that,
you know,
those times,
those times when you were doing exercises
and you why they'd sacrifice a unit to,
that they can accomplish the mission.
I'm not sure,
but I think you're that unit right now
and we're counting on you to get it done.
Unbelievable.
You know, that's, uh, that's
one of those things too where
that's where you're, that's where, you
know, from a leadership perspective,
you are now,
you know,
entering a situation where duty is going
to be the most important thing to you.
And you also know that
the mission is the most important thing.
You've got to,
you've got to put that at the top
of your priorities. And you know,
you're going to sacrifice guys
and it's going to be a nightmare.
But the alternative,
the alternative is you're not gonna win.
You're gonna,
you're not gonna win.
That's the alternative is that your
team is not going to be able to achieve
this. And, and you know,
at this point in the war,
this war was not settled
yet by any stretch.
This world was not settled.
And so to give up ground and start to,
to let the Germans reorganize and
let them start to gain high ground,
which is what they were fighting for here.
Hmm.
That's not just going to affect your mind.
It's going to affect everybody.
And so I've said this
on the podcast before,
the definition of a team is when the
members of the team think the team is more
important than themselves.
And that's what you see right here.
They realize, John's
realize, realizes that,
look, we're going to be, and the
title the book is Clay Pigeons.
You know what a clay pigeon is, right?
Yes. That's what you throw up in the air.
And she would add, and it's just,
it's a sacrificial piece of clay.
And that's why the name of
the book is the clay pigeons.
The St Lo because that's in many cases,
the situation that they're in.
Yeah.
So this is,
this is different then when Napoleon says,
Hey, if you get told to do something and
it's not smart and you do it anyways,
you're culpable. Yeah. John's,
he can't say, look, no,
this isn't smart. He knows it's the
right thing to do. He know that's,
that's the big difference that
I'm trying to get at here.
This isn't a guy who's saying, look, hey,
we're going to charge this machine gun
nest and I'm gonna lose it. You know,
half my platoon, but it's not going
to make any big deal. And I'm a,
I'm a bad leader because I sacrificed
my platoon for a meaningless machine gun
nest. This is a guy that knows
that this objective is important,
knows that this high ground is needed,
knows that the success of this,
not just this mission,
but the success of this whole,
this whole assault on France and thereby
Germany is riding on what they're
doing.
Hmm.
Now you could break it down and
say, well, you know, they made,
they could hold back and they could wait.
Well,
what happens when you hold back and wait?
Do the Germans have meat?
More reinforcements that they're
sending their way that you know what's,
what does that actually mean? And so he
is calculated. It is mine. You know what?
We need to do this for
the good of everyone.
We need to do this
at one point.
Now fast forwarding past some
more of that fighting. They,
they do a good job of kind of
of the they've,
they've knocked out some of the,
through through some fierce fighting,
Dave knocked out,
they've moved forward and they've hold
up and now they started advancing again.
And here we go. Back to the book
of one Peter, one well-placed,
stubborn hostile machine guns
stopped that flank attack cold.
So they're attacking and they get
stopped by one well placed machine gun.
The German gunner got off,
got half of the small squad that tried
to rush him through the smoke and the
attackers had to withdraw,
dragging their wounded with them.
Mortars and artillery left the German
undamaged rifle grenades couldn't quite
hit the narrow slit through
which he was firing two grand.
And deer is trying to take extra careful.
Aim had also been hit by
concealed German snipers.
When the major arrived,
it looked as though progress.
It stopped using the battalion radio to
the rear command post and the artillery
phone.
From there,
he adjusted 18 successive rounds from
one gun of the hundred and 10th field
artillery battalion in a vain attempt
to sharp shoot the machine gun out of
existence,
but he couldn't hit it and after each
round burst on or near the hedge row,
the enemy would reply with
a dis Derisive v burst.
There was only one answer a tank
and miraculously a tank appeared.
So that's what I'm talking
about. He's, he tries with,
there's a one machine gun that's
holding up this situation.
He gets on the radio and
cars, Terry artillery, which
is similar to mortars there.
They're bigger and more powerful, but
it's the same thing. It's indirect fire.
You're putting rounds far up in the air
and then through a big arc that's going
thousands and thousands of feet in
some cases into the air and then coming
basically straight down on a target.
And it's when I say it's
hard to hit a target,
he's fires 18 rounds to try and hit
this machine gun bunker to machine gun.
Can't stop it,
can't help it.
So he needs a tank and then
miraculously and, and uh,
if you don't know anything about my
incredible affection for tanks and for
tankers because of what they were able
to do in the battle of Ramadi too,
not only for themselves, but to support
and save my guys time and time again.
I'm a big fan of tanks. In fact, I love
tanks and tankers. That's straight up.
That's the way it is. And this is why,
this is why right here, back to the book,
one steel monster,
monster lumbered up behind John's who
yelled instructions to the tank commander.
The gunner watched carefully while in an
infantry squad beat her fire to clip of
tracer bullets at the slit that hid the
machine gun and then swung his short
boar barreled little 75 into line.
It crashed once and almost simultaneously
with the muzzle blast came to crack of
white phosphorous shell.
As it hit the slit,
the smoke blossomed up from behind
a hedge row indicating a direct hit.
With that,
a single paratrooper came running
toward them a few moments later.
Everything on the front cut loose.
The enemy and the company charged and
another hundred yards of French real
estate had changed hands.
Okay.
And then the major,
the major wished every machine gunner
in his outfit could have seen that
position as an illustration of what
skill to nasty and guts could do to build
and defend one machine gun position.
So
machine gunners tanks.
Yeah,
that's incredible. What a
machine, I mean you can even,
you know what a machine gun is, right
between machine guns, I mean, uh, uh,
a normal like a mark 48 machine gun or
the old m 60 Roger Hayden talk about
carrying the 60. Right. And
in our boys last deployment,
my last deployment to Ramadi guys
are carrying mark 48 or mark 46,
which is a smaller round of five five
six round m 60. That's what ramble had,
right? That is yes. And
Command. Oh by the way, okay.
I'll take your words from the Matrix to
be exact. That was his knee. Oh, okay.
The [inaudible], the belt fed
machine gun. Oh yeah. They're,
they're not that big of a weapon. I mean,
it's big and blood true. Believe me,
when you're carrying an 802,000 rounds,
it's big enough.
But if you think about a whole,
you know,
a battalion worth guys are getting stopped
by a guy in a machine gun in a good
position. Now he had snipers,
snipers covering him.
Two snipers apparently recovered him. But
that's, that's, that's not many people.
That's why when you're on the offense,
you need more people then being in a
defense position, you know, a defect.
When you're in a defense defensive
position and you're allowed to,
you have time to set up. That's why when
you go back to, well, when you look at,
normally when you look at this whole,
if you look at World War II as a whole,
both the the allies in what we did in,
in Normandy,
taking the beaches and what you
did every time in a Pacific,
taking the beaches, you're going against
bunkered positions like this fully,
and it's just incredible the tenacity
that it takes to make this happen.
Yeah. Isn't that the whole, in a way,
the whole idea behind behind guerrilla
warfare where it's like we're just,
we're kind of fighting,
we're not fighting it,
and then all of a sudden we're
finding that that is the,
that is behind guerrilla warfare, but
this isn't guerrilla warfare. Yeah.
Even without even without sneaking
around. Right, right. You're,
you're in a uniformed soldier,
German and you go, okay,
I'm going to set up a bunkered position
on this high ground it where I have the
enemy channelized in this area and I have
good spread on them and the only weak
spots I've got, I'm going to
cover him with snipers. Yeah.
Three people holding up a battalion
and just think, you know, if he,
if then once you get that position,
we have mortars already dialed in when
you get there that are going to start
hitting you and then the next thing
you do is you got to move again. Well,
guess what? We got another three, four,
five guys in machine gun positions
mutually supporting each other.
Yeah.
That's why this,
this,
these American allied fighting forces
and the Americans here and the Americans
in the Pacific going against hardened
bunkered positions is incredible.
Yeah,
it's incredible.
Now he's given kind of an overview
of war and end. Here we go.
Thus goes battle, a rush,
a pause, some creeping,
a few isolated shots here and there.
Some artillery fire, some mortars,
some smoke more creeping, another
pause, dead silence, more firing,
a great concentration of fire
followed by a concerted rush.
Then the whole process starts all over
again. The defender, this is good.
This is good information. The defender
will almost always hold out some reserve,
even though his front line is being
torn to bits. At least he should.
He may inflict all the damage on the
attacker that he can while giving ground
slowly.
Then when he thinks the
attacker is weakening or when
the defense has reached a
certain piece of ground that the
defender has chosen for the purpose,
he launches a counter
attack with his reserves.
The attacker has used much of
his strength. His men are tired,
probably short of ammunition and are
almost inevitably somewhat disorganized.
Then the defender throws fresh troops
into a counter attack. Overground his men,
no,
unless the attackers are very strong,
they must inevitably suffer often than
they are defeated and thrown back or
destroyed. So there, there you go. I
mean this happens in mixed martial arts.
It happens in sports,
it happens on the battlefield and these
guys are pushing forward on the attack
and you take away leaves,
you chip away at them a little bit,
you give them ground,
you give them ground and then when they,
when they get spread out,
they're low on ammunition, boom.
Then you hit them on a counter attack
on ground that you already know
back to the book.
Such counter attack tactics have been
standard almost as long as there have been
organized armies.
The Germans employed them so regularly
that they were never a surprise,
but the enemy could never muster,
seem to muster the strength necessary
to make their counter attacks stick.
Their efforts often hold it in
advance as they had the night before,
but they rarely gained back any ground.
And we're almost always costly
to the counter attackers.
Even the best and most proven tactics
still require judgment and the force to do
the job.
The Germans rarely had enough of ether,
so there's a little breakdown on what's
happening with the Germans. First of all,
we're not using good judgment, they're
just like standard operating procedure.
We're going to counter
attack every single time.
And when you count her as accurate,
taking losses,
especially if you're not gaining ground,
so their standard operating procedure,
we're going to counter attack
and they're not gaining ground.
And so were they doing,
they're losing guys.
And the more guys you lose,
the less guys you have to counter
attack with the next time. Yeah.
Now
they had a,
they had a group here that
was working in the battalion.
They were called the commandos.
It was just like a little elite
group that they were using.
They would guard the command post,
but then they would also,
when someone's going down,
they'd get out there and get after it.
Super aggressive,
but they were running so low on people
that they needed to put the commandos
team back out into the companies,
the regular companies.
So there had been a little commando unit,
a little special unit
within the battalion,
and then they had to take those
guys and put them back out with the,
with the regular companies.
Now here we go back to the book
in the middle of the afternoon,
the CEO moved up close behind a company
to watch their contingent of former
battalion commandos go into the line.
Sergeant Turner,
who had made it, who had been in
charge of a platoon of the command,
a platoon was with them seeing the major.
He fell behind long enough to say,
sir,
we're going in there to help our buddies
from old a company lick the hell out of
those bastards,
but when we get through this,
I'd sure like to come back and get
it into a bunch of commando's for the
battalion is cool.
Voice ended on a rising note.
All right,
sergeant,
you go to send to St Lo and I'll promise
you get another platoon or your hell
raisers just as soon as we can
spare them from the companies.
John's returned to the sergeants.
John's returned to sergeant salutes and
watched the man as he ran to catch up
with the others. An hour later, a weasel,
which is a small purpose tracked vehicle
flying a Red Cross flag clattered out
of the woods carrying a
load of wounded on litters.
The battalion commander who was passing
the spot stopped when he saw the wounded.
The little commando sergeant lay
on the litter on the near side,
seeing the major.
He yelled for the driver to stop.
John's went over to him and the boy,
both his legs wrapped and
dirty bloody bandages,
grabbed his commander shirt and
pulled himself up on the litter.
He was crying openly and unashamedly as
he burst out with a flood of invective,
they got all my boys made
sure we didn't get off the LD,
which is the line of departure. I
let you down major, I let you down.
He stopped and sobbed bitterly before
you could go on major John's could feel
his own throat constricting as he held
the tightly gripping hands that shook him
again and again as the sergeant poured
out his grief and rage and disappointment,
we had to get that gun. Damn the
dirty bastards. God Damn God. Damn.
I let him get me with a fucking machine
gun and they got all my boys too.
God Damn.
He sobbed uncontrollably while the
weasel driver began to let us clutch take
hold, but I'll be back major, sir.
I'll be back probably back. Sure. Boy,
and I'll have your old job for you anytime
you just take it easy and get those
legs fixed. The major was
walking slowly beside the litter.
Trying to gently disengage
the grip on his shirt.
The sergeant let go and fell
back on the litter exhausted.
John's looked up at the aid
man who slowly shook his head.
The sergeant would not be back.
Now they are finally pushing into
St Lo and and they have to go down.
This direction of attack that
they're taking is down this
down,
this single road that heads into St
Lo and the Germans have it dialed.
They have it dialed with range,
you know,
with artillery ready to hit it
and here we go. They have hit it.
They're starting to hit it with
big rounds. Back to the book.
John's noted that the German
fire was coming in slowly.
There couldn't have been more than two
or three guns firing as they were all big
ones. They didn't fire
rapidly. That was a break,
but just one of those big
shells in the wrong place.
As the next one began to how the men
began to look for deeper spots in the
ditches, John's yelled, keep
going, dammit. It's not here yet.
The men kept going forward for several
more seconds running hard. Now.
The shell was nearly on the ground
before the major yelled again down.
Although the men hit the ditches.
John was too excited to remember
he was in the middle of the road.
He went down on one knee. The shell
burst a hundred yards ahead. Again,
nobody was hit. The incident at burst,
the major was up, yelling, let's go.
Running is he yelled,
his men got up and ran to Hoffman and
grist mill or grim cell catching the idea
moved further back down the line of men
to relate commands and call signals on
the shells. When the next one hit,
all three officers did the same.
None of them got off the road here and
they're non coms without orders began to
fill in the gap staying on
the road themselves. By the
time the third shale hit,
the whole column was working as smoothly
as if it had been on a parade ground
drill and they were losing no time.
They kept going. A few men were hit,
but not many. Oddly, oddly enough,
not an officer or non-com was knocked
out of the middle of the road.
Though each leader only went down
on one knee. One Shell burst,
not 25 yards ahead of the major,
but it hit just around a small bend in
the road and he was sheltered by the bank.
He ran forward through the smoke and
dust nearly falling over a man who is
rolling crazily half in
and half out of the ditch.
John's grabbed him by the arm to help
him to his feet crying. Come on boy,
let's go. The man tried to get up,
but stumbled awkwardly forward.
Only then did John's look down and
see that the soldier had no feet.
He was trying valiantly to stand
on the stumps of his two legs,
whereas feet had been sliced
cleanly off just at the ankles.
John's laid him back gently into
the ditch and changed his tone.
Maybe you better take it easy while son,
you stay here until one
of your buddies gets here.
There'll be a long in a minute.
The man himself was an aid man
and not another was insight,
but the battalion commander
had no time for one man.
So after a quick look to see that the
stumps were not bleeding profusely,
he patted the man on the back saying,
see you later bud.
Then he ran to catch up to his place
in the column a little further down the
road. After another burst, he saw
another man lying in the ditch,
not making any move to get up and go
have though he didn't seem to be hurt.
John Stopped, grabbed him by the
arm and yelled again, come on,
let's get going.
Looking blankly up at him.
The soldier pushed a camera
forward saying, plaintiff Lee,
I'm a camera man.
This rock the major for a moment.
Then he said, well, you can't take
any pictures in that ditch. Get going.
So again, you see leadership in
action. You see him having to exit,
actually lead and set the
example and his other,
the company commanders and eventually
the the senior enlisted guys all follow
his lead of what he's doing. We got
time to run. We got a minute of water,
whatever it is, 30 seconds,
we're going to get up.
We're going to run as hard as we can.
When we,
when we know we're going
to get hit with a shell,
we're going to get down and take cover
pure leadership.
Now once they get kind of into st low,
there's a kernel shows up,
starts getting told what to do. Back to
the book, the colonel was giving orders.
Again, I want you to clear this
town as quickly as you can.
There aren't many Germans in it, but
there are a few and I want it all clear.
Your battalion is the only infantry
we have with the task force.
As you are the ranking officer, you will
be in command of all the troops in town.
He looked closely at the major who nodded,
trying to contain the elation.
He felt knowing that he would have
command on the ground of what would
undoubtedly be a historical action.
The colonel thrust a map at him.
Here's a large scale map of the
town itself. Now get going. Major.
John's turned to look for
Wendell Weddle and Greg Muscle.
His two staff officers turned
company commanders both.
We're almost at his elbow.
He drew them to one side and
divided the town between them.
So now they're kind of on the outskirts
of St Lo and they're starting to clear
the town.
And we have seen the companies go out
and start clearing the town and they've
set up a little make shift
command post for, for major Johns.
And, and he's standing
there with, he's got these,
got a bunch of new guys with him too.
He's got all these replacements.
Because remember on an hour and
a half ago when I said, hey,
these guys have already
had 300 replacements.
Well that has kept up the whole time.
They're getting all these replacements.
So at this point, this is an
interesting leadership story here.
He's got some new guys that show up and
there's, he's standing in his new
command post and these new guys,
he sees like a position that needs
to be taken to make sure that,
you know, we, we have some security around
the command post. And so here we go.
He motioned to the PFC and three other
men standing nearby, they came forward,
rifles ready. So these are three new
guys. Just replacements. Just showed up.
Hmm.
And again,
the probably the most fire they've seen
was running into the town of St Lo,
avoiding big giant how it's or shells
that are hitting him back to the book.
See that alley there said John's pointing.
I want you to take these three
men and go down to the end of it.
Looks like about a hundred yards where
you will set an outpost Lieutenant
Lickeri. We'll come around
later to see how you're doing.
The PFC squinted down the alley,
nodded a trifle uncertainly
and started toward it.
The others followed but the
major was too preoccupied,
preoccupied to note that there have
been no briefing and no assignment of
positions or duties.
They just trooped off down the alley
together like a bunch of men going to the
post exchange.
Two minutes after they left the sound
of German machine gun fire came from the
direction of the narrow passageway.
John's turned to look out of the alley
pelted the four men straight toward them.
The private first class panted sir,
there's a machine gun down there.
The battalion commander didn't
know whether to be amused or angry.
There was no telling what the new men
were apt to do if they didn't have
leadership of an experienced are
well trained non-com or officer.
He decided to be gentle. Yes, I heard it.
Now tell you what to do.
You take these three men again assign one
to take a place where he can shoot the
gun or where you think the gun is.
Then take the other two and see if you
can't come around behind it and get it
for me so they'll cover move. It was
real simple. Look, cover, move you.
You get where you can shoot the gun,
have that guy get,
we're going to shoot the gun and then
you guys maneuver behind. Cover move.
Beautiful.
The PFC took that in,
nodded somewhat less uncertainly
motion to the men to follow
him and started purposefully
back down the alley and
not more than five minutes.
There came in rapid succession,
the sound of the machine gun, a few rifle
shots, two grenades and running feet.
John's had moved across the street
looking for the best place for a temporary
command post.
He turned toward the mouth of the
alley wondering what would come out.
This time to Germans showed first running
toward him at full speed before the
major could bring a sub machine gun up.
He saw the PFC and one other man prodding
the Germans from behind with bayonets.
They spotted him and poked
the prisoner in his direction.
They stopped in front of him before he
noticed the MG 34 the PFC was dragging
behind him, so they actually
had the German machine gun.
The man dropped the gun in front of him
saying, here's the gun you wanted major,
but this is all that's left to the
crew. We had to kill two of them, sir.
Major John's gulped nodded and motion to
gay was another one of the guys to come
to get the prisoners,
the private first class and his helpers
jog back toward their new outpost.
The major looked after them,
wondering just what sort of training or
indoctrination they must've had first to
run away from an enemy
without trying to fight back.
And then to apologize
for having killed too.
He looked down at the German that the
batter German machine gun kicked it idly
and reminded himself to be more
careful in issuing orders to new men.
They were apt to take things
a bit on the literal side.
He was sure that the
PFC had actually fought,
that the CEO himself had a personal desire
for the machine gun they had knocked
out and they would have gone to any ends
to retrieve the gun itself in order to
bring it back.
Just because the major had added that
for me when he ordered them to get the
gun.
Yeah. That's like a common thing to
kind of add. Right? Like in, you know,
back when he used to work at the
nightclub, you'd hear that all the time,
especially when you're
managing big crowds. So you
say, Hey, can you, you know,
can you slide over on the side here
for me? And they'd always add the,
for me always thought like that's
kind of strange thing to add. I mean,
it's so common,
but when you really think about it,
it's like that kind of
a strange thing to add,
but I think it adds like this
personal touch too personal.
All right,
now he's in the command post Weddle
who's one of the company commanders.
These guys were out clearing the
city and he hears some commotion,
comes back into one of the rooms and
Weddles in there with one of the other
officers or one of the other, uh, yeah,
officer's in there working on them.
Back to the book,
Brooks sobbing was carefully cutting away
the officer's field jacket and shirt,
exposing a wide deep gas
just below the shoulder.
John Stomach turned over
quickly when he saw the wound,
the bone was shattered
with sharp, splintered and
sticking through the bloody,
pulpy massive torn flesh.
That's,
this is wet at least talking
about when was damn near right.
They don't almost blowed his
arm plum off the s three moaned,
closed his eyes as he leaned back to let
Brooks duty could with a nasty wound,
but he pulled himself together in a moment
or two and opened his eyes to look at
the CEO. So here he is Weddles
just in agony, but he gets,
gets a grip. Then he looks at the
CEO, squeezes his eyes together,
hard than looks at the CEO and says,
I was just coming back to tell you he'd
ground out between clenched teeth that
we have our side of the town all
clear with the men out on the edge.
When the artillery caught me in the
middle of the street, he flinched.
His face twisted in pain.
When the aid man who had taken over from
Brooks inadvertently twisted his arm as
he sprinklered soulful
powder into the wound,
then he went on Chadwick his back.
Didn't know it until I saw him came up,
just came just before we pulled out out
of the little road back up the hill.
You can put them in command. He's
good. He was gasping at the words.
Now Major, can you get me Outta
here? I don't want to lose this arm.
Sure. Boy, we'll get you out. Just try
to relax now. Don't worry about it.
Take it easy and we'll have you back to
where they can fix it. Up in no time.
Weddle leaned heavily on Brooks,
who was still sobbing from the shock
of seeing his captain so badly wounded.
Weddle and Brooks had been
together a long time and major new,
the sergeant would be no good
around the command post for awhile.
So we motioned him to go along
and look after the wounded s three
so again,
you know,
Major Jones realizes that somebody at
their capacity for handling the horrors of
war and says, Hey, you take this
guy back to the aid station. Yeah,
okay,
now there's a German counter
attacks or they're in St Lo.
The Gut things decently handled,
but all of a sudden they start seeing
it and there's a guy in the field named
Barnes and he starting to report back day.
They're,
they're forming up a big counter attack
and also their field phones or been on
the last wires.
So they're don't have good communications.
They see this thing forming up. They're
going to be overwhelmed. They're,
they're really under man's St
Louis is a pretty big city.
It's all kind of destroyed,
but it's still too big for the
amount of people that they have.
And so they're really scared that there's
gonna be a big counter and the terms
are going to take the city back.
So the finally get through.
They don't even know
who they're talking to,
they're just trying to get through to
somebody that can pass word to get the
artillery just start dropping bombs.
And Henderson is one of the guys on the,
on the radio and he says,
damn it man,
this is the goon red and St Lo when
we've needed artillery is worse than the
ever needed anything and all our
lives when we need it right now,
all our lines are rear all our lines to
the rear out and our wire people spliced
one and got you.
Now quit asking damn fool questions and
tell me if you can shoot for us in St Lo.
So this is going back and forth.
They start dropping bombs and all of
a sudden they start adjusting the,
the bombing closer and closer to them,
to their own lines.
Back to the book Angel Fire Direction
Center was questioning the adjustment.
The correction would
bring the shells inside.
The no fire line may
be on friendly troops.
Hell yes. We got doze on the edge of
town. Who Do you think wants this stuff?
Anyways, the artillery man was
frantic, afraid of the safety rules.
The big guns would make them stop
them just when they needed the most.
Please sir. He pleaded,
just put it out there.
The Infantry Battalion
Commander is standing right
beside me praying for more of
it. The last of all, he was right in
there, but the Germans are still coming.
They stand the, they get them to
drop more bombs, bombs and Barnes.
The guys out in the field calls back in
again. That was marvelous. Do it again,
some more. And then the guys
transfer in that repeat range.
Fire for effect.
Give us all your hand and give it quick.
You're breaking up the
attack and you're all we have
and that's enough.
That's dead.
They bombed the bejesus
out of the Germans,
and that pretty much breaks the attack.
And again,
I'm summing up like seven
pages of extended combat.
Uh, and finally though, the,
the battle is for the most part
over and they've got stabilized.
They kind of set some security.
And here we go back to the book major
John's his face in his hands as he sat
down for the first time in hours,
he couldn't help thinking of the
deaf and agony to so many men.
So needlessly it hurt
damnably deep inside.
Yeah.
And then a liaison officer
for them regiment came in
with a lieutenant colonel,
his staff,
and all of his company commanders.
They were from the hundred and
34th regiment of the 35th division,
which was to relieve the first battalion
at once. John's could hardly believe it.
Even when he saw his replacement standing
there looking fresh and confident,
he was beginning to think that clay
pigeons were supposed to go on forever
fighting all alone,
except for the artillery.
The new battalion commander wondered
about Major Stat Major John Staff.
So he's got a guy coming in to take over.
They're getting relieved
and the guy says, you know, hey, what's
up? Where's your battalion staff?
Back to the book, John's
explained, and as he did,
he reviewed in his mind.
All that had happened in the short 30
days since the first attack and the boy to
tail
his whole forward staff was gone.
Newcomb Sadler,
Carter and McCarthy dead
Weddle and Hoffman wounded,
grim sell out commanding
a company, nab, Ryan,
Todd, stolen cardiac, Kenny and Dedman,
all wounded besides God knew
how many other officers he,
he had never even known by name.
The company commanders from four companies
killed or wounded mostly in the space
of seven short action packed days.
He stopped talking while he thought
for a moment of all those fine people.
When he glanced up catching himself,
he thought he was looking at a ghost.
There stood Kenny the shadow on his face,
wavering as the candle flickered
and the faint breeze of his entry.
So Kenny had been wounded and
now he's back in an instant,
has troubles his
preoccupation with the route,
with the relieving officers
were forgotten. Kenny, he cried.
When in God's name are you doing here?
Well Major. I heard you got into town.
All right, but we're still sort
of shorter company commanders.
I saw Todd deadman and cardiac back there,
so I thought I'd better get on up
here and see if I could do anything.
The docs will let you go these days if
you can stand up straight for two minutes
without falling down.
The major saw that Kenny was exhausted
in spite of his cheerful attitude.
He found out later that he had walked
alone in the dark all the way from the
division clearing station,
several miles to the rear in order
to get back to the battalion,
his legs and back or covered with
bandages under his new shirt and pants.
You said, well old man, there isn't
anything you can do right now.
These nice people who've just come in,
so we're going to be out of this rat
trap and a little while and you just go
back behind Mrs Bland Shit here
and lie down and get some rest.
You need it. Can. He did as he was told,
the strain had begun to bend,
even his indomitable will
at
zero four 40 the major
reported to regiment that
the hundred and 34th infantry
had taken over.
The wireman took out the phone,
the major shook hands and said goodbye
and good luck to the new arrivals.
Then he and Kenny followed the companies
down the hill just seven days ago.
They had numbered 800 they
were now only 450 proud,
tired men.
The clay pigeons who had
taken the core objective
clay pigeons
and from
Omaha beach
to the Elb,
the first battalion,
hundred and 15th Infantry 29th
Division had 2,384 casualties,
including 454 men killed in action.
That that, that's, that's
hard to even fathom. Again,
think about the fact that at
this time a battalion was about,
it's supposed to be about 900 men
and they'd taken 2,384 casualties.
So all the replacements that
came and kept getting wounded.
Yeah.
Unbelievable. And what's, I mean, you,
you got to read this book and
get the lessons learned in,
in also you get lessons
learned from that book. But
you can also get some of major
John's lesson learned from
Colonel David Hackworth in his book about
face and what's you want to talk about
some layers, some, some
historical layers. Check this out.
So in about face,
you know,
Hackworth talks about what
happens in August 13th,
the communist in Berlin started stringing
barbed wire and they were now going to
build a wall between east and West Berlin.
And they,
you know,
Kennedy who was president wanted to do
something like you can't just, you know,
we need to do, we need to make
some kind of a statement here.
So he sent 1500 soldiers from the first
battle group of the Eighth Infantry
Division and they were
selected apparently by Kennedy,
by name. So Kennedy
said, I want these guys.
And the reason is because their commander
was a guy name Glover, s John's.
And he wanted them to go
and reinforce the British,
French and American troops who
were on the ground in Berlin.
And then layers.
Colonel John's in his position
appointed d company in his battle group,
he pointed d company to be the
battle groups reaction force
and who was the commander of d company.
It was a young Korean War veteran who
had come back into the army named captain
at the time,
David Hackworth.
And as I said,
Hackworth points to Glover Johns as his
primary source for leadership lessons
learned and he captured
them coming succinctly from
Glover Johnson himself eight
about face.
So let's take it back to
that book for a minute here.
Okay,
from about face all too soon,
Colonel John's received orders back
to Berlin as chief of intelligence.
So now this whole thing that they'd
gone through with sending this,
this forced to reinforce
the French British and in
American troops on the ground
in Berlin,
this is pretty much done all too soon.
Colonel Jones received orders back
to Berlin as chief of intelligence.
Most of us had known the
magic couldn't last forever,
but it didn't change the fact that we
were incredibly sad to see him go on 15
January,
1962 the battle group fell out smartly
for its final review before our favorite
soldier,
the weather was bitterly cold,
but no one noticed we were all too busy
standing tall and greedily soaking in
the colonel's farewell address.
John's was a leader who taught by example.
So most of the points he made
weren't exactly new to us.
But to hear it in a single speech,
this great man's basic philosophy of
soldiering was like being led down,
letting in on the secret
ingredients of some magical formula
to wit strive to do small things well,
okay,
be a doer and a self starter.
Aggressiveness and initiative are two
most admired qualities in a leader.
But you also must put your feet up and
think so there's a little dichotomy he's
hitting on. Yeah, you gotta be
aggressive, but you've got to think.
Strive for self improvement
through constant self evaluation.
Got To be humble,
never be satisfied.
Ask of any project.
How can it be done better?
Don't over inspect or over supervise.
Allow your leaders to make mistakes and
training so they can profit from the
errors and not make them in combat.
Decentralized Command.
Keep the troops informed,
telling them what, how and why.
Builds their confidence.
Yeah.
The harder the training, the
more the troops will brag. Boom.
Remember that guy that asked the last
podcast, how do I improve the morale of a,
of a group? Get them, get them
to have that pride. Train hard.
Next enthusiasm,
fairness and moral and physical courage.
Four of the most important
aspects of leadership,
enthusiasm,
fairness and moral and physical courage.
Next, showmanship of vital
technique of leadership.
That's interesting.
And there's a bunch of
an about face Hackworth.
He, he specifies some of these
things that he would, that,
that uh,
Glover Johns would do showmanship wise.
He'd walk down the range and he was
a really good shot with a rifle.
And apparently he would
have a guy throw a quarter,
like a coin up in the air and he'd shoot
it because he was such a good shot.
That. And another thing he did, he's,
he's about to give a speech somewhere
and in sort of a mixed audience,
but bunch of German, um,
sort of political people.
Glover, John's gets up and just
gives the speech in German.
All right. Next, the
ability to speak and write,
well,
two essential tools of leadership.
Boom.
Next,
there is a salient difference between
profanity and obscenity while the leader
profanity tempered with discretion.
He never uses obscenities.
Next, have consideration for others. Hmm.
Next,
yelling detracts from your dignity.
Take your medicine side and counsel them.
Next,
understand and use judgment.
Know when to stop fighting for
something you believe is right.
Discuss and argue your point of view
until a decision is made and then the
support,
the decision wholeheartedly.
Last,
stay ahead of your boss.
Okay.
When John's had finished colonel couch
gave the order to pass and review and
company by company, we marched by
with just that little extra precision.
Our shoes,
uniforms and brass earlier attended
to to provide just that little extra
sparkle.
As was the custom the company commanders
peeled off after their units passed in
the review stand and
congregated for final goodbye.
John's had watched the parade
with tears in his eyes.
The tears remained as
he stood at attention.
Okay,
so
tears in his eyes.
That is major Glover,
John's,
that is the clay pigeons.
That is the first battalion,
hundred and 15th Infantry,
29th division.
And obviously he is an
example of leadership
and the men of his battalion,
the clay pigeons,
they are yet a nother
example of the indomitable
warrior spirit and culture that
is the very core of this nation.
Don't forget that.
Okay?
Don't forget that culture.
Don't ever forget it.
And for those of you
out there right now defending our nation,
that spirit and that culture,
it can work to hold you up
and having it in your brain
can keep you strong in trying times.
But there's also a dichotomy there because
not only does that warrior spirit and
warrior culture hold you up,
you also have to hold it up.
You have to maintain that warrior culture
in the way you think
and then the way you act.
And if you ever start to forget how your
spokes to think and how you're supposed
to act,
then remember Colonel Glover Johns
and the clay pigeons
of St Lo.
Yeah.
And I think that's all I've
got for tonight. Echo Charles.
Yes.
So
I guess speaking of
maintaining,
yes.
Maybe you could tell us how
we could maintain support
of this podcast if you,
if you want, if they want.
And for ourselves.
Hey,
what is fire for effect? Oh
yeah, fire surely since. Awesome.
So you're on a radio and you're watching,
you're calling artillery or you're calling
a naval gunfire or you're calling air
support and you're trying to
get them to hit this target,
whatever that target might be.
And it started trying to get him to hit
a building where there's Moose. Sure.
And they get a direct hit.
Now you say fire for effect.
Yeah.
That means you need to
make any more adjustments.
You can just start hammering
that thing. Boom, boom, boom,
boom. Fire for effect. God.
So when somebody does something and it's
on target, you like, yeah, fire for it.
Oh Dang. Okay. I just want it is
one of those ones that you know, I,
I'd hear all you in life
always say it and you know,
how certain do we save that
much? No, not that much. But I,
that's where I would
hear him kind of come out
and you know how certain terms,
if you're not familiar with them you
can kind of gather what it means is,
you know,
in,
in a contact in the conference room
in the words and stuff like that.
But that one I never could really figure
out exactly what that means as opposed
to,
you know,
I don't know fire at will or all these
other things that you hear fire for
effect far perfect cause it,
it kind of sounds like it could mean like
to distract them or something to have
some effect other than hitting the
target and something like that. Yeah,
apparently not.
Apparently it's the opposite and you
know, it's all good. It's just amazing.
Can you show him up with these
these guys man? Yeah. And,
and I'm telling you like,
and I've said this before,
that thread of,
and I actually don't like
using the word warrior culture.
Yeah. Because, because it's so overused.
It's so overused and it, it's just, it's,
it's been so degraded by this horrible,
meaningless things. That guy's a warrior.
You know what I mean? Because he,
you know, did what made it a crime and
actually survived his prison. Yeah. Well,
that guy's real warrior. No,
actually you're not, you know, but,
but there's no other word
that I can put on it.
I at least that I could
think of right now.
When you talk about the American culture,
and it's so easy because America's a big
place and America's got a lot of good
things going for it. You
know, the culture of art,
of art in America's massive,
the culture of music is,
is unbelievably powerful here.
The culture of
education and academia,
all these things are massive in America,
right?
And,
and it's really easy
to forget the culture.
This the most,
in my mind,
the most powerful culture that we
have now. I could be wrong. Oh,
what about our [inaudible]
entrepreneurial spirit and culture, right?
That's huge year. Very strong.
Our capitalist culture,
we want to make money, we want to
grow, we want to do things right.
Those were all really,
really powerful and I
think we tend to forget.
We tend to forget. We want to,
we want to say that, you know,
the Japanese Bushido culture is this
thing. We should look up to. Guess what?
Guess what? That bushido
culture versus the US marines,
you know,
storming beaches in heavily defended
beaches and other guess what the American
warrior culture, that's, that's the
real deal. That's the real deal.
The Nazis. Oh, the
storm troopers. Oh yeah.
Those were such a warrior culture.
Guess what?
Compare them to these guys.
Know. No, not happening. Sorry.
Yeah. Yeah. These, and you
hear this a lot like that.
There was a little part in the book
where the guy got his legs blown off or
something like that and he was like, I'll
be back. I'll be back. He's like, and it,
it really seemed like he was,
he wasn't pissed about his legs.
He was pissed that he's out of the game
for you guys down. I'm going, you know?
Yeah. I think a lot of
times, and you know,
America is kind of what an
example where you don't want the,
all things are going real good.
It's easy to point out the things that
are not going good, you know, like Whoa,
whatever the case may be. Like
when, if everything's perfect,
the little imperfections show
themselves more. You know,
how like if your life is
like everything's together,
where your job is good and your family's
good or whatever, but meanwhile,
like you're, I don't know, your front
line is going down. You're like,
my front lawn is going right. You
know, it's like that kind of thing. Um,
I think that's what we have in the u s
it's kind of like things are really good.
I think it's more just a
matter of percentage. I mean,
I think in America right now it's like,
oh,
1% of the population is actually
in the military. I mean,
all of these World War II veterans
are not many of them left.
Vietnam veterans are getting older.
Korean veterans, veterans are very,
very rare at this point. So, and what
are our movies about? The, you know,
instead of making movies about St low,
they make movies about the
aliens attacking or whatever,
you know. So we just,
it's pretty easy to forget that the
reason we're here and the reason we're not
speaking German is when the reason we're
not speaking Japanese is because of
this warrior culture here, which kind of,
it's right up there.
It's right up.
You show me any warrior culture
that has the same that, you know,
I know there's equivalents,
I know that there's other,
I know there's other military units in
the world and other countries that have a
proud military tradition as well. But you
know, obviously I'm biased towards mine.
Yeah. But, uh,
were you tell me any historical
unit that you say, Oh,
these guys with the Spartans and they
were the real warriors. Right. You know,
you haven't really spent much time
with a 19 year old marine. You,
you haven't spent much
time with a, with a, with,
with a soldier from an airborne
division. You just, you just,
you got to meet those guys. Yeah. I'm
telling you. They're the real deal.
Yeah. And no matter
what kind of, you know,
historical warrior you want to,
you want to throw out there,
I'll put my Americans against
the head to head it just,
it terms of just straight up
warrior culture and spirit.
I'll go, I'll go toe to tell, I'll
go toe to toe for sure. I'm not,
I'm not trying to say we're better,
but I'll go toe to toe with the Spartans.
Yeah. I'll go toe to toe with
them. I am just talking, you know,
my warrior culture against your warrior
culture and the way you lived your life,
you go, go meet some of these young
soldiers and marines out there.
You can come and talk to me and,
and special operations guys.
You know what I mean?
Obviously come and get some,
come in fire for effect. Sorry,
do it. I just learned the word.
I'm trying to hit it in warrior culture
doesn't get through all of America.
Nonetheless.
We are down to support ourselves.
I wasn't gonna make some wisecrack about
Hawaii, but you know. Yeah, you might,
you might get dealt with.
No, not going to do that. No,
because just a massive,
there's a,
there's a great book that somebody sent
me and it's about Japanese Americans
that formed up, you
know, we sent American,
sent many Japanese to internment
camps in America, in World War II.
They also took a bunch of them and
turned them into a fighting unit.
But the four 47 yes.
And they were,
they might be the most highly
decorated unit of their,
of that size because B,
but a lot of them came
from why? Yeah, yeah.
It's a huge Japanese community in
Hawaii. Yeah, sure. Yeah. Yeah.
And speaking of Hawaiian [inaudible] hall,
like the and Warrior culture,
Hawaii for sure.
Yeah.
So am I allowed to just straight up
say Bj tender right now and my boy Max
Holloway, by the way, by the way, car
Max came and trained with us. Yeah.
I've told this story before, but man,
what a board, a beast. He, you know what?
He was trained in hard.
Yeah. He was trained hard.
He wasn't even close to the UFC yet.
This was years ago.
It wasn't close to the UFC yet. He hit
some warrior culture and them, yeah,
get some super nice guy too.
And when you,
when you can sit her like
even let's say the sparked in,
then you consider all
their battles and stuff.
This is like hand to hand soared to
nec battles. Just like Dang that's,
that's savage.
But back in those days look
at all kinds of cultures.
So consider Hawaiian culture.
If you look at the weapons like you can
look like in museum, just go online,
whatever,
look at the weapons that they used in
battle and then consider like that's what
you got to use. It's like
savage, like Plu. Yeah there,
there are legitimate where your
cultures but it is different.
There's no doubt.
And what I'm saying to,
to encapsulate what I'm saying is America
has one and it's told her toe with
any, I don't slip and sleep on that. So
support, support wise. I'm going
to shift gears here. So, I mean,
you know, I, I'm talking
about kettle bells all to,
I feel like I'm talking about not just
now feel like I talk about kettle bells a
lot.
It's one of those things,
you know how like you go from
thing to thing and you're like,
Hey I'm going to go to one.
You go from thing to thing.
You know, I try to acquire knowledge
and what do you call it? Skills.
Capabilities. We'll say
capabilities that's important.
Participation is required.
Kettlebells is kind of like a thing that
I recently got into and I'm going to be
honest with you.
You can kind of good at them Jack.
Cause considerK and here's, I'm
going to go into numbers, whatever.
So my metcon was,
his wit was um,
I'll do one 35 can I knew jerk cleaning,
press dreck,
whatever presses.
Like just pressing night jerk is kind
of like you jerk your whole body kind of
thing. Okay. So it's
clean and jerk one 35,
you know the wheels, uh,
five and then two burpees,
five walked for 30 to 35
seconds. Boom. Do it again.
So anywhere from,
I dunno
to about eight sets would
be like a solid one.
Usually 32nd walk. By the way,
it's like, uh, the recovery.
It's like, it's like you're breathing.
That's why. Okay, so it helps. Wait.
Why should I not do that? I'll be going
to five, five, five, five you wouldn't,
I challenge you right now.
We're going to do it together and you
just go five five oaks. We can go longer.
Well, I don't want to do that.
Well, I might die. Contest
wouldn't be to go longer.
Well, whoever, whoever stops the
rhythm. I'm saying that the rest is,
it's part Rico here. Here's the goal.
That's why. Well, let me ask you this.
How long does it take you?
Like 30 seconds to do.
Does it take 30 seconds to do the five
and five? Yeah. No, no, no more. None. No,
no more than 30 so you do five clean
and press right. Boom. Five burpees.
Yeah, it's more than 30 seconds.
Maybe 45 at the most, maybe 45 yet.
I Dunno. That's a good question. And
it's more than 30 though, for sure. Okay.
Well then I guess it might be all right.
So put that on a timer though.
You shouldn't do sand like a minute 30
IBS for 30 to 35 you should be like, okay,
I'm doing it all because you're saying
like the Tba, well you should do,
you should do a minute,
30 seconds every no and every minute and
30 seconds. So you do the five and five.
Okay. So that way you get, cause by the,
by the six set you'll be like
tired when you're starting it,
but you don't want to rest more push
yourself. This is kind of my thought,
my thought process on it is I'm going
to do a certain kind of work capacity,
you know like you know,
five reps of this and five reps of
this and then I'm going to have,
have a kind of an active
recovery period walking. Yeah.
And here's the thing and here's kind
of the goal. This is good. I actually,
I actually am going back on what I said.
I think this is actually not a bad
idea because, but you need to put,
it's like when I do,
sometimes I'll do stuff on the minute.
What makes me nervous about what you're
saying is that I like rest for about 30
and 35 seconds. No, I don't know
what that means. Okay, okay. Because,
because that could be 40 seconds.
That could also be, it's not,
you've got a clock on. Yes sir. That's
100% yes. So the, here's the weird thing,
but having a clock ever since I started
lifting rest between sets has been a
critical part of my lifting routine
from the beginning. Rest between,
because that's just what I
learned and stuff like that.
So I don't think the clock and actual
clock is not been a part of a workout
ever. It's part of the way.
It's like, wait, there's weight,
just like you're lifting those weights.
That's what the weights are for. The,
you're going to rest in between sets.
That's what the clock is for.
You can't just go willy nilly and be
like, Hey, I'll just throw on whatever,
and that's just my philosophy.
I'm not on the clock of a one hour
workout from me would take like two hours.
Yeah.
I'll just,
I'll just be thinking about something or
I'll just take more rest than I should
have taken or whatever. Yeah. And
consider this, if you're doing,
let's say you're doing five
sets of squats, I dunno, eight,
we'll say you're pushing
on your second set,
you can do more weight then or less
weight then on your first set if you rest
for less time there. Right. So if you rest
for five minutes, you can do way more.
Yeah.
So that's putting your body through
something different than if you would've
just rested less.
So it just depends on what you're trying
to put your body through while you can
recover from. And what kind of
results we want to goals on.
Or one of the hardest workouts is,
and this isn't,
this is discipline equals
freedom field manual.
I used to do the 20 rep squat workout.
Sure.
Which is you take away that you can do 10
times, you do it 20 times. Oh yeah. Okay.
Sorry. And, and it's, it's
devastatingly hard. Yeah.
And I would rest for 20 minutes and then
I would do it again and then I would
rest for 20 minutes and then we'll
do it again. So three sets of that.
That is okay.
So tech and I believe you,
I'm not saying it's easy, I'm not
saying that, but that being said,
technically that's impossible.
Technically yes, you're right.
It is impossible to do something
that you only do 10 times, 20 times.
If you can do the weight that
you intend for him to 20 times,
that's the way he can do for 20 days
straight. That's not 10 right. So I get,
I get it, but I'm not going to,
I'm not going to, you're right.
But you also understand what I'm talking.
I know exactly what you're talking about.
You're like a normal,
like you're not maxing out
at 10 reps with this weight.
It's like this is my normal.
Maybe if I'm going to do a set of Tanner,
she'll be surprised that
the way you can get,
like let's say you know,
you,
you pick the right weight that you
can like I can do this 10 times. Yeah.
Legitimately. And then you're like, you
know what, I'm going to do it 20 times.
I know, but you're right.
But I think that's like a curse
of knowledge kind of situation.
Like when you say I'm going
to do a weight 20 times,
what I can say for lack of better during
the normally do tan, it's not normal.
Also, you're like, you're basically,
you're resting as much as a human being
can rest with a bunch of weight on their
back in between Reps. When you get
to rep 12, you're taking like time.
But it's, it's, it's a really,
it's a losing proposition because
while you're waiting there resting,
you're actually suffering
and your backstory to get
old in there. Yeah, yeah. No,
yeah.
The overhead squats are a brutal because
you're not resting in an overhead squat
position and it's like awkward
and yeah, that, that's hard.
The overhead squat situation, but,
and not to beat a dead horse here,
so like consider if you said,
hey, uh, someone who's pretty new,
more or less to work it out. Say, Hey,
get a weight you can do for 10 and do it
20 they're going to mess up in one way
ticket. Probably they're going to be
like, okay, I can do this 10 times.
I know that and I'm gonna try to do 20
and they can't even get to get 20 because
you said the weight that they could do
for 10 they try for 20 they feel it 10
that's how much they can
do for 10 or they'll go the
other way. There'll be like,
you were like, oh, get up. And they'll be
like, wait, I got to do this 20 times. I,
yeah, I can do this. I
can do the bar 10 times,
so I'll just use the bar kind of thing.
So you have that knowledge where you,
you're like, Hey, I know the weight
that I can do for 10 and it'll be hard,
but you know what, I'm going to get
nuts. And if I really pushed myself,
I can get 20 guess what I'm using.
Not Wait.
So you kind of have that because you've
been training, so I get it. Yeah,
you're right.
And I don't think I'll ever do that
even though I kind of considered it last
time you mentioned it, but then when I got
in the, in the workout room I was like,
yeah, I don't think I'll ever do
that. Maybe I will. I don't know.
You were actually, I'll tell you
what I will do. Is someone online,
maybe it was you. Someone was saying a
hundred burpees in 10 minutes. 10 minutes.
Was that you saying? Yeah.
Yeah. And Brent. Brendan just
texted me yesterday. Yeah.
Brianna branch. Cherry. Yeah.
He said he's going to do it.
I was considering I'm going to
do it in the first time I did it.
That's what I saw was
surprised at Brandon.
Brandon's a good shape to the receipt.
He be post like pictures of himself
doing these crazy pushup workouts. Yeah.
I can't believe he can't do it.
That's why I'm so surprised.
This is what I'll do is a weird,
he has good creative pushup drills.
Does creative pushup drills, I don't
know. He'd doing this weird stuff.
He puts his hands up here.
Over there. Yeah. That's good.
Yeah. Totally good. Yeah.
Cause you ever trade lake. I got
good at push ups when I was thinking,
actually I'm still pretty
solid that pushups.
But you tried to do a pushup with like
adjusted. You're like, oh this is way off.
It's kind of like goes back
to what we were saying.
It's like what you used
to do your neuro muscular.
Speaking of what we were saying
something about kettlebells,
we kind of wrap up right now and
then you started talking about other,
the other crazy squat.
You don't what it is my fault
next time I won't tell anything. Yeah.
Yeah. See that's what, that's what I see.
What you did there.
Look,
you took blame you and you told me what
you're going to do to fix it. Yeah.
Dang. Extreme ownership in
effect. I'm also, okay, wait,
what were we talking about? Oh yeah,
I'm into kettlebells. No. Yeah,
and you want to say where are
you should get your kettle walls.
I'm not saying necessarily where you
should. I'm seeing where I got them. Okay.
And if you want you,
you kettlebells anywhere where really?
What about cool kettlebells?
Ooh, okay. Whoa.
That's a different story in my head
anyway. I don't mind from on it.
I'm not even saying get
the cool kettlebells.
I'm seeing gold on at.com/jocko
Lukey the kettle bells.
You liked those kettlebells.
If you're going to get into kettlebells
or if you're already currently into
kettle bells, get some of those
if you like them. I like them.
I got one. Uh, the small one. It's
called a howler little howler monkey.
Yeah,
I think it's a, anyway, howler
monkey, kettle bell. It's like a,
I won't say 18 pounds.
What's 0.5?
Pooed a bounce and Prudy 16 pounds.
Yeah, no, no, no, no. 16 kilos I
think. Oh, sorry. 16 kilos. Yeah. Yeah.
So yeah, so eight kilos, 16
pounds, give or take. 70 18.
Anyway, I got one of those for my
daughter. So my nephew comes visits.
He's 11 not into working out.
We'll just say that is now is
now. Yeah. So I'm like, you know,
he's one of these kids, he's like,
you know, he's into math and whatnot.
So I'm working out all the time and I'd
never really thought until someone may
be kind of suggested it to say, hey
come work out with me, you know,
so I tell them come work out and he,
I kind of caught them at the end where
it was metcon time and he and I was like,
hey come work out. Cause I saw
him, you know, and uh, he's
like, yeah, he's like cool.
Immediately do by the way, you'd be
surprised. I'm not surprised. Yeah man.
Working out. They're like, man, I want to
be like dad. You know, in their, on some,
remember you saw somebody that was all
yoked. You're lucky. Do you, how do I do?
That's the whole reason I work
out to be honest with you.
Like remember the show American
gladiators. Remember that.
But it was not from what I was a kid.
Yeah.
I didn't watch it the way you were
apparently. Yeah, I was watching that.
I was like, Bro, I want to be an American
guy. Cause they were there. It was like,
cause there was the mix between these
big kind of almost like bullies,
not bullies, like a bully
people, but they were like,
you know when you play the video game
you come against the boss who you look at
them, you're like, I can't meet this guy.
I can't beat them but you and you're
a normal character or whatever.
And then they ended up winning and that's
what American latter years was in real
life.
And I was like Dang this
American gladiators or or
or money cause were athletic
too. I was like, man, I I, I'd watch
it and I do a bunch of pushups.
I was in like sixth grade or something
like that. Yeah, it's a whole reason.
Anyway, I think a lot of
kids have that in their mind,
especially the boys for sure in
one way or another. So I was like,
hey come work out with me. And he's like,
he was like, okay, let's turn this phone.
Yeah, he was on the phone. Not Anymore.
Boom out there. Uncle Jake scenario,
uncle Jake,
100% I was uncle Jacob that
time legit nephew is there.
Visit. Actually he was visiting me. I
wasn't visiting, but nonetheless he comes,
I teach him the form and
kids kind of have good form.
Well he did cause they're flexible.
Yeah, they're flexible. They,
they haven't fallen into
like improper patterns.
Maybe like make adults ever or something
maybe. I don't know. That's just a guess.
But anyway, so I'm like, you know,
just the basic kettlebell swing. I say,
this is what you're going to do. Do
it. I'll do it. I'll show you how.
Give them little little tips or whatever.
You know,
it wasn't perfect for him at first.
You'd adjust and he could do it.
Not the kind of all the way up or nothing.
Just so basic. I was like, all right.
And my daughter happened to be there
and just so she knows about burpees,
so I was like,
okay,
what we're going to do is you can do
kettle bell swings were five and then
you're going to do burpees and they're
going to walk for 30 seconds basically
matter.
Yeah.
But he's doing the Kettlebell swings
rather than the clean and press.
So then you can do burpees.
Burpees has just jumped down,
do a pushup and then jump up
in there. That's a burpee.
So he does it. I was like,
hmm. Well on the, you know when you
transitioned from standing to push up,
there's a loop. There's some wiggle room
there for air. So I, I tell my daughter,
hey, demonstrate, she does. She's four,
she can do it pretty good too by the way.
So she does it and I'm so of course he
can do it. He sees a little girl did.
So he does it, makes the adjustment.
Boom, he's good to go. He's ready.
So I'm being fired out cause mine's about
to be super hard like it normally is.
And he's like, you could tell he's
getting fired up too, you know.
So I set the clock and we go and his
is kind of easy to be honest with you.
Cause the Kettlebell swings compared
to the yeah. And Boom, they kid did,
did the whole thing and he's all
sweating afterwards, you know,
and he's the kind of where he doesn't
do that kind of stuff, you know?
But you could tell he was super fired
up and you know what he said next.
He said afterwards, he's like,
hey, next time you work out,
can you let me know straight up. I was
like, God Dang. Uncle echoes in the house.
In the house. Man in the house.
Yeah, so she read a book about that.
Yeah.
Maybe I will.
It will be the best book
ever forgets next anyway,
kind of what's going on it.
They have a lot of good stuff.
You ever done the battle ropes before?
Yes. You have, but not never have.
They were in some random Gmr was
at the time I was gonna have,
I've seen people doing this. I'm going to
do some of them. Yeah. They're like big,
big ropes and the, I guess that's a good
exercise. I had never done them before,
but I was considering that.
I saw some on there anyway,
was a lot of good stuff on
it.com/jocko checkout, all the stuff.
Really good stuff. Stuff for everything.
Basically everything getting after it.
Also good way to support is when
you get your copy of about face.
Of course that's already on
it, on our website, Jocko,
podcast.com that's the website.
If you didn't know clay,
the clay pigeons of St Lo,
that's the current book we just went over.
That one is on the website as well.
It's in the little section menu item
on the top of the website, Jocko,
podcast.com click books from episodes,
boom,
the list of books by episode.
Click through there and before you
tweet me and tell me a good book that I
should do on the podcast check and
see if I've already done it. Yeah,
it was like what?
Like 60 bucks or so and a lot of
really good books that everyone knows,
but if you haven't listened to the podcast
and then you're telling me to cover
with the old breed by Eugene sledge or uh,
whatever,
just so a lot of times people telling
me to cover books that have already been
on there. Yeah. So then I got to go
and figure out which podcast it was.
So I can tell you to go and
listen to podcasts, you know,
10 which is what the old breed by Eugene
sledge. There you go. I think. Yeah,
something like that. But if hey, hey,
go and check that out. Like I said,
it's all there by episode and if you
want a boat, a reading list for me,
that's my reading. That's it.
Yeah. There's no other books.
If a book is good and I read it,
it's been,
it's been on the podcast and I'll do you
one better cause I have a small reading
list that I added to that
list. Oh, that's only one book,
but I'm just saying he's playing
games. Yes. Powell. Michael Lough. Um,
you know, that's an easy read.
It's kind of like the field manual,
a small little version, different
subject. But nonetheless,
it's not like the field manual
duty. I haven't read it, but I know.
No, no, probably not. Anyway,
um, it, as far as supporting,
get your books through their
click through, it goes to Amazon.
You Shop Amazon like we all do anyway.
Right. So when you get these books,
like I said,
listed by episode,
Click through there and if you're doing
other shopping, hey, feel free. You know,
when you click through there
that say small little action,
big reaction as far as support those,
you know, kind of like, you know,
when you thorough sodium metal and
water, you know, oh I know. Yeah.
No, you know, for, I haven't
said it for a long time,
so I'm gonna say it now just to remind
everybody when you throw sodium metal and
water, it explodes. Big. Huge
Ellen that in chemistry class,
my chemistry teacher's name
is mister Bigelow by the way.
Quite high school back in the day.
Anyway. Also good way to support,
subscribe to the podcast on Itunes,
stitcher and Google play and other
places that they do podcasts and leave a
review, leave a review. Here's
the, if you feel like, yeah,
that's really what it is.
Reading the reviews. But yeah,
if you feel like leaving one apparently
it's like, Ooh boy stuff. I don't know.
Yeah, good. Yeah, good, good. And
that's great for sure. That's great.
Helpful and spreads. What
does it do? Spread the word.
I think ultimately that's the benefit.
So you don't want to see our
Jocko podcasts on you know,
number whatever where it
appears like between one and
10 in the business section.
That is good.
That's cool.
But really the tangible
benefit for the message is,
is spreading the word people.
If they get turned on to it,
it improves everybody's life really.
Because if you improve your
life in all these ways,
it improves like your improvement re is
a direct effect on my improvement cause
I hang around with you. So that's kind
of how it, so that's really the benefit.
So if you want to help spread the word,
yeah,
can write a review and if you want to
give feedback about the podcast and that's
a good place to do it. Yeah, I
think that's, and let's face it,
when you leave a review,
especially the ones that everyone leaves,
cause p it's kind of fun.
That part is fun and people aren't people
people like take time and the reviews,
they're not like good podcast. Yeah. Well,
actually, sometimes they do say that.
Good emphasis on county capital.
G. O. O. D. Yeah.
That's how fast layers layers
in the review for the day.
But I'm telling you. But anyway,
yeah. Hey look, if you're in the mood,
leave a review, you know, as long as
you're honest, that's the main thing.
And you know, get colorful with it if you
want. Those are actually the fun ones.
Like I said anyway, Lee Review.
Yeah, sure. If you, if you
feel like it a subscribe,
subscribe to the Youtube. We have youtube.
If you didn't know. Everyone knows.
I think. Yeah, cause
we see it all the time.
But in the event of this being the
first time, subscribe to it though.
Why wouldn't you?
Why wouldn't someone subscribe to it
if I were a person who all weight,
if you're listening to this
podcast, it makes sense. Yeah.
I don't know how many reasons there
would ever be to not, this is why.
That's the reason I listen
to the podcast audio. I look,
I go to youtube and I only watch people
playing first person shooter video
games. You know how that, I don't know
if you know this, but that's the thing,
like people will watch other people on
youtube videos playing shooter games.
Let's say I'm only into that,
I'm probably not going to subscribe or
actually this one's actually a legitimate
one that I can kind of dig and relate to
is if my youtube subscribing situation
is only two kids stuff only to get stuff
because every once in a while I get my
phone to my kid.
Okay.
And they watch like you know they watch
like Peppa pig or I dunno something.
Well and then when they click on,
a lot of times the podcast is just
what the podcast is on Youtube.
But like the other day you released a
deleted scene or wasn't even deleted.
There's a prerecording we were
just talking. Yeah before.
And people seem to think it was pretty
funny even I thought it was quite funny.
So yeah, cause when you're
detached it is really funny.
But the thing is if
someone wasn't listening,
if someone's not on subscribe to Youtube,
they would never know that that
existed and then you miss it.
I initially pretty funny. Yeah.
I thought it was funny too,
even though it was Kinda kinda harsh.
What'd you call me?
Getaway sticks or something like
that. Anyway. Yeah. See now you're,
you just went into the
reasons to subscribe. Oh,
there's a whole reason. Good.
Cause you know the excerpts
that we make put out.
Just cut tiny segments.
Three minutes nowadays,
take lead the scene was 16 you know,
that's different. But it was pretty funny.
Yeah. Uh, but the excerpts, you know,
they're just like individual ideas that
you talk about. Boom, sharable. All good.
That's a good reason to subscribe to
Youtube. One of the many. My opinion also,
Jocko has a store, it's called
Jocko store. Jocko store.com.
That's the URL on there. What
do we have? Shirts, rash guards,
rash guards. I, we started
for Jujitsu. But here's the
thing. Rash guards are first.
Surfing and body boarding and jacking.
Steel Jacking.
Steel. Yes. Cycling. These
are all, that's what really,
it's a spandex shirt.
There's little things.
The term rash guards
only applies to surfing.
And because you're not
worried about getting a rash
when you're lifting weights,
you're not worried about
getting a wreck, I guess. Yeah.
I guess in Jujitsu or something like this,
yeah,
guard you against a rash
or or ringworm or whatever.
Nasty. Yeah. So nonetheless, I mean the
point there is that it's for everything.
Just because you're talking about
Jujitsu all the time, you know,
it's not for everything cause
I don't want to interrupt you.
You know, get after a
rash guard. Well that's,
you can speak for yourself because if I
saw someone at the club with a get after
it, rash guard, I would, I would
say good evening to that person. Oh,
that's a good point. And I
guess I can't be mad at him. No,
no, no rash guards when you're
out not doing activities.
I'm not a supporter of that. Yeah. You
know what to be, to be completely honest,
I don't know that I would support it.
I mean just like, Hey, I'm going out,
I'm going to a supermarket,
put on my good after it crashed.
I guess if you do this, like you never
know what's going to happen. Yeah.
You might want to be ready.
Right. It's true. Yeah. You know,
you get some good workouts
in a grocery store yourself
for long line, straight here in
the rash guard, your compression,
you're ready to absolutely true.
And you know you want to look into that.
Go to jungle store.com so
the shirts on there, I,
you know, I tried to add like a
new one every like month or so.
I don't know what your goal is.
I Dunno if I,
I've been wearing Bronson's children
tee shirt. Me Do. This is the one,
cause that's, that's the, that's
the shirt that you made or neutral,
the one that you made with my
face on it. Whatever. Dang.
So I'd always get caught up on the
front like ha ha, that's funny.
The front and all the layers in the front.
But on the back it says good evening.
So when you wear that one, that's when
people are going to talk to you the most.
You know how like you don't worry the
one with your face on it every day,
there's no reason for you to yeah,
it would be weird.
Yeah. You need to exactly enough. Nope,
look at that. Um, but
if you wear that one,
it says good evening on the back.
So I never really thought of this.
I haven't worn it. I don't even have
one. But that's the one I'd wear.
This one good people will say something,
it would look good or be like, cool,
you're good. It's backward. You're
sure it's backwards. I don't know.
Or who's that guy in your
church? Whatever. People will
will say something to you.
The good evening one,
they'll talk to you even more,
but they'll do it from behind and
they'll tell you good evening.
Every single time. Interesting. You
haven't worn it yet. How do you know this?
Cause I know, I know the
compulsion. Like I know the feeling.
That's my hypothesis anyway. And from
what I hear from the field anyway,
go on there. If you like something, get
something that's a good way to support.
There's some hats. Oh really? Released.
Coming out within one
week about that. Cool.
Okay. Alright. There it is.
I better have like nine of them lined
up at my doorstep because I need some of
them hats. You got it bro. I promise. Um,
so yeah, some patches on there as well.
Anyway, check it out. If you
like something, get something.
Also psychological warfare,
if you didn't know what that is,
it's an album with tracks.
Jocko tracks is Jocko talking,
getting you through various points
of weakness in your I've been,
I've been really trying to think of
a word to say other than journey.
I haven't yet. So we're instinct with
journey. So when you're on your journey,
you channel wake up, wake up
earlier, maybe I will do it.
You're trying to work out where you're,
you're trying to work out
every day, every day. No.
Even on rest days you're doing it
MobilityWOD for sure. Like this. Yeah man.
Sometimes you want to turn those,
those workout days, interest days.
So don't do that.
And if you need a little spot with that,
you listened to psychological warfare,
there's a track for that for any
point of weakness. Like I said,
get after it. Psychological
warfare, Amazon music, iTunes,
various other MP3 outlets,
Jocko Willink. And now,
uh, first, if you haven't heard yet,
we are now in the league
with origin USA little company and we
are now a part of it has been months in
the making.
We've been going back and forth with my
boy Pete Roberts and who actually this
is you went up about layers.
The reason that we are linked up in the
beginning was because of Sarah Armstrong.
Sure. Who, who heard me talking
about how cool origin was.
Yeah. That they make everything
in America. And she sent
Pete an email and said,
hey, I know you run this company
and this guy was talking about you.
You guys are talking to each other.
Guess what?
We talked and now we're getting after it.
And we joined forces and so we're
planning all kinds of things and uh,
gear [inaudible], rash guards,
planting some supplements.
And believe it or not, is the
rash guard back in stock? Not yet.
We were doing a little, we're doing a lot
of building right now. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Uh, but we got all kinds of
things coming basically. You know,
basically I want to make everything
that I used to get after it. Yeah.
I want to make so,
so everything and um,
and when I say everything
is not a long list,
I don't use that much
stuff to get after it.
I use a pretty small list but I want
to make it and I want to make it in
America.
So if you wanna check it out,
check out origin main.com cause it's in
New England, which are where I'm from.
It no big deal. Layers, layers. Indeed.
And also if you want to get into it,
like now you want to find
out really what's going on.
There's an origin immersion, Jujitsu
camp in Maine. I had realized,
I hadn't even explained what is
you receipt. Oh see I'm from New
England so I know what this is.
I know what after camp is you, you may
or may not know people in other parts.
Of course you may or may not know.
A camp in this form is in this
situation it's a big lake.
And on the lake there's a property and
on the property they have a bunch of
little cabins, a bunch of
them, like multiple cabins.
And when you go to a camp you stay in
the cabins and then they have a kind of a
central area.
Well we are renting out the entire camp.
I don't know how many cabinets, like
dozens and dozens of cabins. Right.
All these things on a lake.
And then there's a main
kind of gathering area.
Well guess what we're putting in the make
it guess what we're putting into main
gathering area.
Lynn on the Mat.
So we're gonna go, you know, if
you want to come, you come up,
you come to Maine,
it's three hours from Boston.
It's an half an hour from
Augusta, Maine. We're going to be,
their echo and I are going to be
there Tuesday, Wednesday and Thursday.
There's two sessions that are going on.
The first one's the 20 the
20th through the 23rd I think.
Yeah. The 20th through the 23rd so
echo and I are gonna be there Tuesday,
Wednesday, Thursday. We're going
to be a part of both sessions
and so come to that. And what we're going
to do is we're going to train Jujitsu,
but you can only train Jiu
Jitsu so many hours a day.
So what else are we gonna do?
We're gonna hang out with
the cruise cruise big time.
We're going to do some kind of,
there's a big lake there so
you can't surf from the lake,
but we'll figure something.
Water activity out. Right.
And they're making lobster.
And I don't like lobster,
but I'm going to have steak and you
can have lobster and, and uh, yeah.
So we're gonna be hanging out weight.
The lake is the lake cold?
Can we swim in the lake? You can swim in
the lake raising cold. How cold it is.
I don't know,
but I don't know the temperature of light,
but main summertime it will be. It
was not going to be freezing. Okay.
I don't think. And if it is good,
it's good for your muscles recover.
And also during the,
so during this thing too,
if you come up or if you can't make that
and you wanna come up for this. Anyways,
we're having the grand opening of
our new origin factory in Farmington,
Maine. So big factory, 20,000 square feet,
I think it's bigger than
20,000 square feet. Uh,
everyone's invited to that calm hangout.
You know, I was thinking we'd do like,
we'll do like a Q and a or something.
We'll hang out. We'll bro, I'm Rick books.
We'll just, we'll just kick
it. So come up to that.
That is the 23rd of August in
Maine. Common hang out. Like I said,
what is the Jujitsu part of it? What,
how does that work? Like the, you know,
there's two weeks you can go for the
whole thing. No, it's not two weeks.
It's a one week long. It's from the 20th
to the 27th. What is brutal? Two sessions.
So, so what do you mean sessions?
Like what? We all just roll.
You have different teachers. There's
different teachers, but, but you know,
I think we're doing, I think it's three
sessions a day of Jujitsu. Yeah. I mean,
how, how many sessions can you roll hard
at? So some of them can be like, hey,
you know, I'll drill some
technique with you. Or Hey,
maybe you could go over some foot
lock stuff with me or whatever.
You know what I mean? Yeah. I think
there's gonna be some of that and,
but then there's also a bunch of different
black belts are going to be there to
hang out, show moves. So you're immersion.
That's how you learn.
Gotcha.
So I know Naco Nolan's coming to that
from the west coast. He's coming out.
He does. He hit me up. So yeah, come on
up to that. We're gonna have a good time.
Also when we're there,
we're going to have some Jocko white tea.
So if there's anyone that wants to
instantly dead lift 8,000 pounds,
you can get the Jocko white tea.
If you need to crush an academic test,
get Jocko white tea if you
need some. Right now, you
can get some on Amazon books.
We've got some books
for your kid or whatever, kids, you know
we've got the way of the warrior kid.
There's lessons in there for everybody.
Check it out if you want the first
edition of discipline equals freedom field
manual,
order it soon or go to your bookstore
and tell him you want to get it.
Preordered it whenever you got
to do Amazon, Barnes and nobles,
your local bookstore, get it.
Now I'm going to tell you,
don't get this book for
your Wine Sipping Book Club,
not a book for them. They won't
like it. You're part of that club.
Don't get it for them. You can still get
it, but don't bring it to the book club.
They're, they're, they're sipping
wine. They're not in a game.
But if you want to get
stronger, tougher, smarter,
healthier and more prepared all around,
better person.
Get the book disciplining
cause for your field.
Manual comes out October 17th which
means they're printing it almost now.
So that means if you don't order
it isn't going to be backed up.
You're not going to have it.
Everyone else is going to have it.
You going have an edge on you,
maybe you never recover like that
battle I was talking about earlier.
You know someone else gets the
edge on you. You just get Megan.
Also extreme ownership, own it, refer
to it, highlight it, implement it,
spread the word, get it for your
team, your company, your organization.
Wrote that with my brother Leif Babin.
So if you don't have that,
then you have copies for every
single person that you've ever known.
Get it for him. Also, Echelon
Front Leadership Consulting,
assessments, instruction
me, Leif, Babin, JP Denelle,
Dave Burke.
Get the team organized and coordinated
for action and for victory.
That's my recommendation.
If you want to get that process going,
email info,
an echelon front.com finally,
the monster is September
14th and 15th in San Diego.
All the other monsters have sold more
than half the tickets for San Diego have
already sold out.
So this is going to sell out.
Don't get left out in the cold.
You can register
at extreme ownership, dark, calm.
And if you need to talk to us before you
see us at the immersion camp in Maine
and before you go to the monster in San
Diego, you can find us on the interwebs,
the Twitter,
the Instagram,
that Facebook key keyboard and also,
okay,
snapchat. You're on
snapchat. I'm on it. I'm,
I'm learning from my children. Okay, good.
That's the way people communicate.
Now the snapchat and I looked
one of the pages. Guess what?
Wall Street Journal's on there. The
economist is on there. It's not,
it's not this thing for your teenage
14 year old kid anymore. Well it is,
but yeah, well maybe I got out of the
basement as well, so maybe, I don't know.
There must be something to it.
I don't know.
I'm talking to rubbish but
like I have a snapchat,
I don't use it and I haven't like,
you know,
I think you've got to
like confirm your account.
I was doing it because my daughter
likes to make the faces crazy faces.
My youngest daughter likes to do that too.
So she did it on my wife's phone all
the time, and then she hit me up for it.
Like, Hey, let me do, she call it
snapchat. So she's like, let me snap chat.
She doesn't know what it is. She thinks
it's just a face. So I'm like, all right.
So I tried to do it. Then somehow I've got
to confirm. I was like, Nah. So I didn't.
But um, yeah, I guess I'm like one foot
in one foot out kind of thing. Well,
I'm not really, I haven't
posted anything yet. Yeah,
I almost did. I'm sure I was like trying
to figure it out. Yeah. Yeah. Dang,
that's good man. But jade told me, well,
this is what Jay told me, which was smart.
Yeah, this is what Jay told me, your
brother Jade. I said, you know, it's just,
I don't really understand it. And he goes,
that's why you need to do it. I know.
I said to myself, okay, you're
right. Don't like, Oh, oh,
I'm afraid of something.
Why am I afraid of it? Don't understand
it. How do you overcome that? Yeah,
because apparently it's a good method of
communication and men J and not to say
jade said so, so it's
right. I'm not saying that,
but he's real smart with that kind
of stuff. Like he knows, he see,
he knows the trends so he can like
predict shit. Those were stuff like how,
you know, how like how it will work
and who's going to, he is. In fact,
what he does now is AI,
artificial intelligence with
applications and stuff like that.
So he knows that stuff.
So it's like when he kind of says he
can't help but be like, ah, you're right.
You know, even if you
don't know, you're like,
well consider the source kind of thing.
In fact,
he got me into cryptocurrency investment,
so investment and I'm up 30% that's all
I'm going to say about it. So I'm like,
alright. Yeah, hate to give him him
the credit for that. But you can't,
you can't help it. Yeah. Good.
Well you can find us on the interwebs.
Echo is an echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally,
thanks to everyone that
makes this podcast possible.
First,
our military.
Okay,
whose strength and true warrior
culture allows us the freedom
to do what we want to do.
And thanks to the police, law
enforcement, firefighters,
paramedics,
first responders who are ever
vigilant and always ready.
I was just driving back from Yosemite
and their big forest fires up there and
all kinds of people had signs out
saying thanks to the firefighters.
So thanks for you guys up there in
the mountains fighting the fires
and to the rest of you
that are out there working,
building,
making.
It's squeezing every
ounce of life that you can
crushing every minute
of every day out there,
leading in the face of adversity and
doing everything you can to be everything
you can.
All you.
Thanks for being in the game with us.
And thanks for getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.